I'll go meet other girls. We'll just break we'll break up. >> No,
they No, you won't because I'm going to make it hard for you
to ever have be in a relationship. >> One HP voice. One
HP voice threats.
Diabolical combo. Okay. And says that she wants me to kidnap
her. Even saying I want to be tied up, taken to the woods, and
pounded, so maybe there's something wrong with me. I respond
by saying that we should not have in the
Okay, I'm going to go and I'm going to read this summary of the
allegations from before. Okay,
so the initial allegation from Sacramento 89, that is
the girl who Tom is currently going to in this video, basically
Sacramento 89. She alleges that she was in a relationship with
Tom.
um that he constantly was focused on his own Kiwi Farms threat,
that he interacted with a ton of e-irls and cheated with a ton
of EA girls, that he kicked holes in his walls around the time
he basically some girl who got hacked who had pics of him, you
know, let him know that she got hacked and he was like losing
his mind, kicking holes in walls, that he collects blackmail
on women, that he that he records women without consent and that
he is very rough during Okay,
let me see here. Uh, she says Tom lied to her about being a YouTuber,
which is almost certainly not true, right? We'll find that out
as we go and look through this. And then, oh, and I guess the
last allegation she had was Turkey Tom compliment states by saying
she was 15. They look 15, which is interesting. There's another
girl left for dead in the Kiwi Farms thread or Clorox Katie as
she's been known online who also made some allegations that Tom
is rough during that he recorded without consent and that he
bruised her. Now, I would say her allegations haven't been sort
of categorically disproven in any way from what I saw, but I
wasn't paying as much attention during her section of the video,
so we'll we'll give it another watch. I do think,
man, we'll see exactly how it goes. Right. But
let's just say Tom Tom does a very very very good job. So the
allegations are Oh, and sorry, the other thing that Sacramento
was mad about was that Tom engaged
with a Bel Deline sort of lookalike who did a lot of age play
stuff, who put a lot of very younglooking posts online. Like
they were an adult. They were like 25 or something. They're an
adult, but they tried to look as young as possible. And Tom hit
them up on Instagram and then went to go and have sex with them,
like that is another thing. And there's some other stuff floating
around about Tom sort of having like an age play fetish that
he likes being the powerful person in the relationship that he
likes
uh his girls to look like small and dainty and all of this stuff.
Okay.
All right.
And oh, and
just skinny.
He wants girls to look young. it seems
Now, is that a preference or a type that is normal and fine or
is it like a totally harmful possib
more dangerous? I mean, that's really hard to tell without more
information. So, without further ado, let's let's get to his
video and we will see
precisely how he deals with this. I man, I can't even I can't
even hold back, dude. He he kind of wrecks them. Okay, if these
if these people weren't violated against their will before, they
have been now. Okay, Tom
Tom goes pretty hard in this video. Okay, it's pretty >> I'm
sorry that this >> and it's not, by the way, the important
thing here is Tom is not going around the edges and finding the
He's not doing the techone thing. He's not doing the Destiny
thing. He's not finding some tiny inconsistency,
right, to go and put them back like he's not finding some tiny
inconsistency that he can just drill down on. He is finding he
is taking the substantial allegations, their story, their their
precise allegations and refuting them directly at least for the
Sacramento thing. Again, we'll listen to the Clorox skating
so long. I wanted to make sure I had all the
>> I'm sorry that this response took so long. I wanted
to make sure I had all the facts together before saying anything.
Recently, I've been accused by an ex-girlfriend along with an
exartner of non-consensually filming encounters, being so rough
and inconsiderate during encounters that it bordered on
oh encounters, being so rough and inconsiderate during encounters
that it bordered on assault. Encouraging eating disorders, being
into age play,
>> oh, encouraging eating disorders was >> litany
of other completely baseless false accusations. The two women
who are accusing me, Sacramento89, real name Rowan, and Left
4 Dead, real name Katie, took to Gossip Forum Kiwi Farms, to
post the accusations along with carefully cherrypicked screenshots
to back up their claims. These claims aren't super difficult
to debunk just because of the overwhelming amount of evidence
I have on my side. Um, so without further ado, let's start with
Sac.
Uh, to be clear, for most people, I think the biggest thing I
see here is that Tom
being completely like skitso level paranoid about this happening
to him in the future is what saved him here. Okay?
Like that. There's no human being on earth except for Tom who
would be as careful as he was in his DMs. It's like he fully
expected this, which is already a little concerning. I I don't
know how you get into like a genuine loving trusting relationship
like on a real level with this level of but you could see how
meticulous he is to not let anything
slip through in text. It's crazy. Yeah. Texting for an audience
that's what it seems like the entire time. It's pretty crazy.
>> Or Rowan. This is a girl I dated for about 7 months
from May of 2025 until January 10th of 2026. 4 days later she
made her first post. Here she alleges that I am a real freak
and like to quote record encounters without asking for consent.
This is blatantly untrue. I have never recorded any encounter
without explicit consent. As a matter of fact with Rowan, she
was the one who initiated the idea of filming in the first place.
On Tuesday, August 19th after
Dude, this is rough. Like here's the thing. If you're going to
make an allegation like this, you should put this stuff out yourself.
If you I mean, probably she shouldn't be making the allegation,
right? Probably. Not that this is, by the way, this is isn't
necessarily consent to automatically record. It is contextual,
but leaving stuff like this out so the other person can present
it makes you look bad. Okay. Yes, Tom's dry ass text. That That's
my thing here is the whole time Tom is basically like a totally
a robot in his in his messages. It's really funny.
You should get those meta glasses when you crack me. For what?
Cracking time. Cracking time. Oh, yep. Good night, Tom.
Like like he's
man, he texts like a like a 16-year-old Mormon guy. Okay, it's
wild. I don't What are we doing here? >> Each other and
being active. Rowan texted me saying, "You should get those Meta
glasses when you crack me." I responded by saying, "For what?"
And she answers again, "Cracking time." Alluding to me filming
her with the glasses onboard camera. Now, at the time, I did
not feed into this. I did not show enthusiasm. I didn't even
agree to get the glasses. I just responded and said, "Good night.
Sweet dreams." So, one whole week goes by without us talking
about it whatsoever. And then on August 25th, Rowan texts me
saying, "You should get those Meta things for real." So I respond
by saying I think I'm going to avoid filming anything involving
after a while showing that I am clearly not the person interested
in filming our
Given recent events I am paranoid. So what I'm not totally sure
on is with regards to this message. Is this referring to the
leaks from the Ellie girl, the creepy hoarder girl?
I'm not just timeline wise I'm not 100% certain that that's what's
going on here. Right. But I think if that's that's totally understandable
that if he had just had, you know, a bunch of his leaked or a
bunch of his like used to blackmail him that he'd be like, you
know what?
You know what? I don't want to I don't want to do that for a
while. >> She is. As you can see in the text, even when
I say I don't want to film us having, she pushes the issue. Now,
to be clear, we did eventually take videos of ourselves being
intimate. But I was given explicit consent every single time.
And on a few occasions, she even took the phone out of my hand
and was holding it while filming us. To be clear, there was never
a tripod or a hidden camera. It was always handheld. And in every
single video, she was clearly aware of the camera making eye
contact with the camera lens. Also, on September 8th, Rowan texts
me, "I do miss it though." In regards to our interactions, she
follows it up by saying, "Send the videos." Keep in mind, these
are videos that she claim.
>> Okay, I can do that. In fact, I don't mind it. Get off
my soap box now. I do miss it though. # send the videos. I won't
leak it or be hacked or whatever. I can send them later though.
I don't want to look at them right now or I'm going to pop a
stiffy. Okay,
now wait. Did he send them though? Or do you just like try to
put her off? I will watch and keep them close to my heart like
you, my little interactions. She follows it up by saying send
the videos. Keep in mind these are videos that she claims in
present day were taken without her consent. She
Yeah. I and like the videos,
here's the thing. The videos could have been taken without explicit
consent or something. Possibly there's a case here, but with
all of the other things going on around this, like implied consent
isn't impossible.
It's not impossible. And I'd say it it seems like here
likely that realistically if she was if she was looking into
right it I know we laugh at like the Destiny thing with implied
consent. It's because you're implying something. You're you're
taking that implication from things where there's no signal being
given here. There's like a million signals being given that this
is okay, right? She's looking directly into the camera. She's
holding the camera in some of the cases. She is, you know, asking
him to get the glasses to film them during.
It seems like she's quite happy to have this stuff. And
yeah, it gets it gets even worse from >> He then goes on
to say, and I quote, "I will watch them and keep them close to
my heart." Clearly indicating she has no problem whatsoever with
them existing. I'm an extremely paranoid person when it comes
to my personal life and and my life and my dating life. Uh, as
as a public figure, I just like to keep my private life private.
So, I was very hesitant to send Rowan any videos we had taken.
However, I did send her one single still image from one of the
videos where my face is obscured. I guess there was some lingering
thought in the back of my mind that if her accounts were not
locked down super well and if she had been hacked, then the videos
could have been made public. Now, there's an implication she
makes a few different times that I'm basically blackmailing her
with these videos.
>> Someone asked, "Oh, boy.
uh you had any intention of getting
>> so he didn't send them. No, it seems like he didn't
send them. Now,
I think probably in a relationship, what you should do if you
if you didn't want to send them, if you're like, "Hey, I'm not
comfortable with somebody else holding these," then that's something
you should discuss and just say like, "If that makes you uncomfortable
filming more, then we don't have to film more. But I'm not going
to let videos that have me in them go to anybody else's like
be in anybody else's custody." I think that's totally reasonable
for him to say that, right? He should have deleted them. Well,
if he hasn't deleted them by now, then he's a
But yes, I I fully believe that if you take videos with a partner
and they ask you to delete them, you should delete them, right?
That they could retract that consent for you to to possess those.
Like, I don't think that's necessarily a legal thing. I don't
even know. But I do think that if somebody asks you to like delete
videos or photos you have of them, you should just respect that
personally.
Especially because if you're exiting a relationship, you there's
you know how
I always tell people who ask me like um
when people like
have a hard time dieting, okay? You know where the easiest place
to diet is? It's in the grocery store, right? Like if you're
go to the grocery store and don't buy food for yourself. That's
like the easiest way to um to make sure you're not eating junk
food, right? Is you just don't buy it at the grocery store. The
same goes here where it's like don't let your anger or impulsivity
at the end of a relationship be something that pushes you to
take material you have that could obviously like get you put
in in jail or or get sued. Don't hold on to that stuff when they
don't want you to have it and risk like getting in a fight later
or something and you want to make a threat with it or you want
to use it in some way, right? Just get rid of it. Just get rid
of it and then your emotions can't take over.
Easy. Don't let your Don't be beholden to like your emotional
state later on by holding something that you don't even want.
Yeah. Exactly. Control your environment. just like there's so
many ways that you can be disciplined just by not letting yourself
ever enter a situation where a lack of discipline could kill
you
and I just it's obvious he should do that here. I'm guessing
I'm hoping he'll say in this video that he >> sort of like
law enforcement involved but I feel like I feel like you answered
this where you just want to try to compel him to delete whatever
he has on you and that's like the like the extent of your interests.
And if he I mean if he doesn't I mean I I don't know. I really
I'm kind of confused about what to do. But we'll >> At
no point anywhere did drone provide any proof of me threatening
to release these videos of us having or threatening to send them
anywhere. So she has no reason to believe that I would ever release
them. The idea that I, a person who makes a living as a public
figure, would publicly,
I will say Tom is discounting the idea here. So what he did do
was he did talk about how he had a blackmail folder on his ex-girlfriend.
Okay.
that he felt like she might post stuff on him so he could post
stuff on her. And there is absolutely an implication there that
that's something Tom would do to an ex. Therefore, if he's holding
the videos, I do think there is like an implication there that
he might not have intended. I would give that to him. Maybe he
didn't intend it because a lot of the things where you could
read negative intented on Tom's side, I do think he sort of dispenses
with here. He sort of dispels those.
But I do get how somebody could think, okay, well, he's got a
blackmail folder on his previous ex. Now I'm angry at him. I
do wonder if he'd use that material against me. I think that's
like a reasonable
I do think as soon as she said that and he's like willing to
delete the videos >> release videos of me [__]
my ex-girlfriend to get back at her is so insane. Not only would
that incur reputational harm beyond belief, but also serious
legal consequences. The >> idea The idea that I would ever
follow through on this blackmail scheme is totally crazy. It's
like, well, yeah, it is,
but
uh it is,
but in these situations, people don't necessarily think rationally
all the time, right? And I'm not even talking about her. I'm
talking about Tom. Like, if she hurt him badly enough,
I feel like
she could fear that, right?
Like, what if Tom just censored a bunch of stuff? And I don't
know. I don't know. Hypothetically, I I do understand the fear.
Even though he has more to lose from getting in that fight, I
understand her fear. >> The only person who has ever sent
an image of us having sex to anyone is ironically Rowan. Days
after I broke up with her, she without my consent sent the only
image she has of us having sex to the owner of Kiwi Farms. Here,
listen to him describe it. Oh, and one other thing I I forgot
about this, but you actually uh Sacramento had sent me a picture
that was like censored. Um, apparently the only picture that
he would send you is one where his face isn't clearly visible
in it, but you can I can tell the desk like his computer is moved
onto the table, but I can still see like the monster is like
on the the cozy that's like
I
now I'm starting to I'm starting to get this weird feeling with
this video now. I'm starting to get this weird feeling with Tom
where
it's not anything cancelellable,
but I I do wonder if he is going to pretend he doesn't know exactly
what he's doing in this case.
Like he did seem to be wanting this girl to be his girlfriend.
It's like totally one-sided. He doesn't seem super invested like
in a lot of his responses. I'm trying to think of maybe maybe
we just don't have enough of the text. There's this thing going
on where he clearly doesn't trust
And I wonder how you build like an actual long-term relationship
if that's the case.
But then was he even trying to build a long-term relationship
or was he sort of like dangling the long-term relationship when
he really had no intention when he I understand she's having
she's giving red flags, but I do believe Tom represented this
to her as a long-term relationship as something he wanted to
try and get married eventually. I don't see him, by the way.
She says that and I don't I don't recall him disputing that in
this video. Okay. So, that is something that I do believe stands
unless I hear be disputed in this video. I haven't heard it yet.
Okay. And
I'm a little concerned that he was stringing her along in a way
that like this was a predictable outcome. This blowing up was
a predictable outcome.
Right now, is that that's not illegal. It's not what he's accused
of. Just kind of like scumbag behavior. It's not. It's not illegal.
It's not It's not evil. Well, it's it's pretty bad depending.
But Tom's still >> on the table like the exact same position.
So, I can tell that's clearly his desk. >> I guess I just
find it ironic that someone who's accusing me of blackmailing
her with her nudes literally sent a picture of us having to a
man that she has never met. Now, Josh recounts seeing this image
and talks about how hard it looks like I was grabbing Rowan on
the mouth. essentially using it as evidence to support another
claim she makes that I'm too rough during which I find very interesting
because after I sent Row in this photo, she texted me saying,
"I like when you cover my mouth like that." again. She texts
me ask
dude dude
dude there's so many how this is one of those things where it's
just hard to believe like
how could she make this allegation when all of this stuff existed.
You know what I'm saying? Like
at looks the videos and she says yeah whenever you're not locked
in send the videos it will fix me for about a week. Goon sash.
This is clear evidence that she has no problem with these videos
existing. To this day, she has provided zero proof that the videos
were recorded non-consensually
or that I was blackmailing her with them or that I had any intention
of sending them to anyone. Reason being, I never did any of those
So, this is like in my opinion,
I think if you've never had one message where you show like very
explicit concern, there's like one message where she's a little
concerned about Tom being rough, right?
And in that message, Tom goes, "Okay, I guess we could have glass,
right?" Kind of implying he was going to be rough during anyway,
but we could have less. I It's like he kind of pulls back in
that one time. So again, there's not I will say
there were allegations
and we were mostly going on her word. By the way, I I said we
need to wait for like more evidence that you couldn't hold Tom
like really responsible for any of this. It's like maybe establishing
a little bit of a pattern, but there's just I didn't I didn't
believe there's anything like if you were professionally associated
with Tom, there was nothing here to me that would make me professionally
disassociate from Tom yet. Okay.
Anyway, we uh we keep going. I'll back it up a little bit. had
any intention of sending them to anyone. Reason being, I never
did any of those things. In Rowan's interview, she claims that
I never asked for consent to film these facts and says that she
wouldn't notice I was filming until 30 seconds to 1 minute into
it. >> I'm not sure of an exact date, but maybe like 2
or 3 months into our relationship, he would like he never asked
me. He would just pull out his phone and record
and
I wouldn't notice until maybe 30 seconds and a minute or a minute
into it. >> Now, I obviously can't and would never show
these videos to anyone, but um in them it's undeniable that she
is staring directly into the camera from the moment the video
starts. She never once questions why I'm filming or what I'm
doing because the reality is that every single time we recorded,
I had explicit permission. Ask yourself, how could she >> Oh,
bro. Do you think Tom, And I I wonder I'm of two minds on this.
Do you think Tom's kept these things cuz he's concerned about
it coming out and he might have to like actually
That is That feels like almost a valid
You know what I'm saying? That he's like held on to the videos
cuz he feels like I'm going to have to prove that she was literally
looking into the camera in these videos.
have never consented to filming >> when she's literally
holding my phone next to her face as she sucks my dick. In the
interview, she says that what really concerns her is that I wouldn't
send her any of the videos we took. >> I had asked him
multiple times if he could please send me the videos. So, like
he's not the only one who has videos of me naked and he either
ignored the question or was just like no. As I said earlier,
I was paranoid to send these videos to anyone, even her, for
fear of them leaking. Weirdly, in messages at the time, she seems
to actually get it, saying, "I want to see them videos, goon
time," before following up by saying that she actually understands
why I'm scared to send them to her. Now, we're going to fast
forward to October. >> Hold on.
Let's see the videos. Goon time. I understand why you're scared
of my first big Yeah, I'm paranoid. Sorry. I hope you study.
Okay, so I think as the relationship starts,
we have to find the time. I have to find the timing on the creepy
hoarder. So, again, Tom had a former partner who had their hacked,
right? And that he was like freaking out about this early in
the relationship. So, let me go see if we can find
some of that stuff.
The Turkey Tom timeline site got taken down. Okay. I'm not totally
sure about it. I just I don't know if that's what's making him
paranoid. I don't think it's the Destiny thing because this would
be months after the Destiny thing >> by saying that she
actually understands why I'm scared to send them to her. Now,
we're going to fast forward to October 17th in our text and Rowan
says, "Do you ever go back and watch our videos?" And I reply,
"Yes, I do sometimes, actually." Rowan, >> is got his homie.
>> Dude, my my Twitter tab just started playing audio.
Okay, whatever.
Um, I'm not that worried about the first name being here. I'm
I'm really not. It's like I I think Tom shouldn't have put that
out.
And yet at the same time,
at the same time, I do think that like uh I can understand the
anger. I don't think he should have put it out. I think obviously
the
the harm that could come to her is fairly disproportionate
versus what she could put onto him like physically, right?
He says her name a ton. Yeah, I know. I know.
I know. I know.
So, this is the concern is Tom's saying the first name here quite
a bit. And I think that's all he ever puts out in this except
for he puts out a profile picture as well. Okay. >> She's
thinking about that right now and then says quote, "Need that
big white." It's also kind of strange to me that at the time
she referred to them as our videos, but in the present she's
claiming she doesn't even want them to exist. On November, >> Tom
had to make sure that he gets every every single time that she
says he's got a big He found all of those and made sure to prioritize
getting those in the video. Okay. He started the script and the
scaffolding for the script was okay. All the time she says my
dick is huge. Get those all in. Now, how do I build the story
around this? Okay, let's go. Let's go and ask me why I never
asked her for nudes. I say I have a bunch of videos already and
that's why. She does not express that she has a problem with
me having the videos. She doesn't complain about it. She doesn't
say they were taken without her consent. In fact, throughout
the entire relationship, she was sending me nude photos of herself
unsolicited every single month. Why would you send nude photos
of yourself to someone you think could use them against you?
Rowan personally posted dozens of screenshots of our texts, and
not a single one shows her bringing up any of the videos being
non-consensual. Another interesting fact is that during our breakup,
she texted me a pros and cons list.
This is Yeah, sorry. Sorry. The um this is a very big thing as
well is that there's not a single point in the DMs before their
breakup where she ever suggests once that the videos are non-consensual
or she doesn't want the videos recorded. And there are tons of
places where she says that she likes the videos that she likes
that they were recorded. She thinks about them. Yeah. Like unfortunately
the the it seems like the broad basis of all of this stuff points
in a direction of she totally was consenting to those videos
being recorded. Now,
is it possible that maybe the first time he went to record that
that happened without her giving explicit consent? That's possible,
but it's almost impossible to prove now as well because there's
just so much explicit consent being given like before, sorry,
um after and then implicit consent being given before like, hey,
you we should record, hey, we should record. Hey, we should record,
right? It's it's almost impossible to know. Like I I couldn't
give a lot of weight to any allegation because again on both
sides of it, it just seems like she was into getting the sexual.
>> Another interesting fact is that during our breakup,
she texted me a pros and cons list, which she apparently had
written about me on January 4th of 2026.
And in the con section, she complains about a lot of things,
but she doesn't mention non-consensual videos whatsoever. With
that out of the way, we can move on to Rowan's claim that I was
abusive towards her. In that same pros and cons list, Rowan wrote,
"Says he likes hurting me during and making me bleed." This also
reflects her public claims about me, but the great irony is that
I never even said this. She did. On September 14th,
>> 2025, Rowan sent me a text saying, quote, "I'm such
a freak. I like when it hurts and bleeds after something Wong."
In one of her public facing posts about me, she posts an interaction
which reads as follows. She says,
"I
man uh there's a there's a thing going on here and I haven't
seen
something Wong is funny." Yes. There's like a thing going on
here where this girl had to make it very clear when she's posting
on KF and I think not a lot of people remember this. She wanted
to make it very clear that she was not like a crazy girl like
Tom is usually into. Okay, she's not a crazy girl. she's not
like the other crazy girls and that Tom would consistently tell
her she is not like the other crazy girls he's dated and
or like he's he likes that she's normal. This girl is not normal.
She is like totally terminally online,
right? Like terminally online. All right. We haven't even gotten
to the the edges of that yet. All right. And
yeah, I bro, it's
I'd say if Tom was actually laboring under the like I don't think
he was actually deluded into thinking this. He was saying, "Oh,
you're not like the other girls I've dated. She's exactly like
the other girls." Okay. Exactly. She just didn't have the tattoos
or the child's wardrobe that he normally goes for, but like in
by the by the color of the soul, it was the exact same exact
same as like the other girls he'd gone after. Okay. quote like,
"We don't need to do it three times in one day or do it so hard
I hurt and bleed." And I said, "Well, if you don't want to have
as much, we don't got to. We can do other things." And she says,
"Okay, I like doing other things, too." The way this screenshot
is cropped, it comes across like I'm some like just like super
callous freak who's brutally jackhammering her like >> that
is how it comes off diamonds. But in the full uncropped screenshot,
her immed Okay, like doing other things, too. For the record,
you are just as lustful in this regard as I am. I am not alone.
I'm a freak. She says the B the PWC addiction has taken hold,
it seems. But also, I want it to still be special in the future
when we are more serious. I know it has, but yeah, I do consider
with you special. I don't feel I don't consider it fleeting or
silly. I do too. I always miss it. Okay, so he hasn't necessarily
said he's going to like be more sensual or something here, which
is what she's asking for, right? She's not
maybe that's not clear to him, right? That she's saying, "I want
like it's very clear right here that she's like, I want it to
be more sensual. I don't just want it to be like uh I want it
to be the same the same as it has been." And I feel like he's
not necessarily >> to me after that is I'm a freak. I say
this and as soon as I see you, I'm going to be freaky again.
I can't resist. In the interview, she elaborates on this even
more spec. Man, I think Tom's not understanding there
a little bit that it's very hard to do in like a relationship
is figure out where a partner sees something where they're like
scared to even assert the things they want. Right? That's what
it seems like is she's like, "Well, I want, you know, more sensual.
I want less like rough sometimes."
And then he's like, "Well, you like this stuff, right?" And she's
like, "Yeah, I say this." But then, right, it was this soft declaration
she had that she might prefer something else sometimes. And then
she sensed that he wasn't really taking that and she's like,
"You know what? It's um it's okay. I don't need to I don't need
to we don't need to do that. It's fine." Actually, I say that,
but I'm going to I'm going to want to do it rough again anyway.
>> But that's something you pick up with like experience.
It's something that's difficult to pick up in the moment.
>> going to be freaky again. I can't resist. In the interview,
she elaborates on this even more. Specifically,
>> it's not even necessarily power dynamic stuff. It's
like relationship power dynamics. Like some people are very like
giving in relationships. They don't want to they want the other
person to be as happy as possible and they will like set themselves
on fire to make the other person happy. So
that people can be like that and it's difficult especially
it's got to be difficult if you're like a millionaire at 20 or
whatever
guy who has all this attention online. It's probably very difficult
to sense that and not real not think like everybody does this
for you anyway because they just you're awesome.
Like it's probably it's it's the traps you fall into as a 20-year-old
millionaire, okay? Like 22 23 year old millionaire is everybody
wants to give you attention all the time. You're like this very
famous guy from YouTube and he probably just thinks that's like
his due from the world and so he doesn't even realize that that's
what's happening there. Again, this is not like cancelable stuff.
It's just little comments on the side that >> she would
bleed almost every time we had Okay. and you would bleed uh the
same >> and you didn't stop.
>> Yeah, I would bleed almost every time. >> This
is just blatantly untrue as well and it's easy to see by going
through our text messages. On August 17th of 2025, the day after
my birthday, Rowan and I were planning to go to mass and she
wanted to have with me. So, she texted me saying, "Tom, I started
my period." I was driving, so I couldn't say much, but I replied
by saying, "That sucks. I'm 40 minutes away." She follows up
by asking me if I mind getting my sword bloody. And >> if
anybody was curious if Tom has autism, crippling autism,
then I say I'll be okay. So, if it wasn't already clear, she's
asking me if I'm okay with getting blood on my
Why would this be something she's even asking if every time we
have I'm making her bleed? Keep in mind, this is months into
us going out and being active and she's still worried that the
idea of bleeding during would gross me out. Now, as soon as she
began posting about me, people were naturally perplexed by her
claim that she was bleeding from every single time. They asked
if she had some kind of medical problem. And she
she says
naturally perplexed. No, not so come on. Naturally perplexed.
I' I've heard it's part for the cause. >> I have no health
issue that I know of. Never bled during before. It was the I'm
just gave into it after a while and told him I liked it, but
I bled after almost every single time. I feel like most of this
statement has already been dispelled, but even the smallest detail
of no medical condition that I know of is also false. On September
24th of 2025, Rowan texted me saying that she's going to switch
from her current birth control, Nexplanon, to the pill, because
she has month-long periods that cause her to bleed. So regardless
of Rowan admittedly bleeds for an entire month at a time. One
of Rowan's main
going to mass and after before marriage is crazy.
Um I mean people come into their faith in different ways. I don't
I don't really think that's that crazy, man.
I don't I don't really think that's that crazy. I'm sure a lot
of young people who go to mass probably engage in
like I don't know. Is that true? One month. I don't know. She's
saying it's true. So I I don't know.
Come to their faith. Yeah. Lots of people do it like
like you're not going to immediately go into some new religion,
especially when you weren't raised religious like Tom,
and immediately like adopt the strictest measures, follow every
single like stipulation of the religion dogmatically.
That's just never going to happen, right? And by the way, no
priest I I don't think any Catholic priest would ever tell you
that you should. I just don't I don't believe that at all. Right?
Like they'd say, "Yeah, I know. You should keep coming. You'll
eventually get it. You'll eventually realize why this is important."
Right? They'll say you shouldn't do that, but they'll
they'll just be telling you like, "Hey, just keep coming. We'll
we'll work on it. You'll get better." >> Criticisms is
that I'm too rough. In fact, she describes our interactions as
intense violent aggression every single time. I I genuinely did
think that he would maybe change and stop being so aggressive
because he told me before that he would like kind of chill out,
but he never did chill out and it kept being the same very
intense violent aggression every single time. >> She also
alleges that I hit, choked, and beat her without asking, essentially
painting me as an abusive partner. Unfortunately, I did still
stay with him and I know a lot of people seem to have a lot of
questions about that. And
honestly, you were completely correct to question my judgment
as to why I stayed with him even though he was, you know, hitting
and choking and beating me. >> There's this idea she's
trying to paint that in the relationship, I was constantly pushing
this rough, violative onto her and even though she didn't like
it and was being abused, she stayed with me. I've seen some people
question her, saying things like, "Well, if you hated it, why
didn't you just leave?" But realistically, sometimes people do
stay with abusive partners. And I don't want to invalidate their
stories through my response. The
Oh my god,
that's actually um that's
that's something that essentially nobody who has allegations
so far has been willing to admit. I feel like the last 50 things
we've watched, they'll basically go like, "Well, this person
said they liked me while we were together while while they say
I was abusing them." And doesn't that prove that like they they
wanted it the whole time? But Tom, you know, taking it one step
further and going, "Hey, just because she said it was okay, doesn't
mean it's okay." I what I think was happening here is this person
I think this person downplayed how big a fan they were of to
Turkey Tom from the beginning. I think they were a fan of Turkey
Tom. I think they started dating Turkey Tom. I think they let
him get away with some stuff. They let him do stuff that they
weren't always into all the time and they wanted to be the perfect
girlfriend to stay with him and they probably pushed in that
direction a lot and it was almost certainly more or less invisible
to Tom and that sucks for her that she would have, you know,
been making these sacrifices been like she wants something different
in and she's not willing to assert that boundary at all. But
there's only so much like you have to say something. Tom can't
know that Tom is not a mind reader. In fact, he seems a little
bit when it comes to this stuff. You almost certainly would have
had to be explicit,
right? The real reason that she didn't leave is because she loved
having sex with me and throughout our entire relationship was
constantly begging me to validate her fantasies. In this first
screenshot here, she >> Oh, god. Well, hold on. Maybe.
Hold on. >> That she is a real freak and says that she
fantasies in this first we've seen tomorrow's teachings screenshot
here. She expresses that she is a
Do I have to read the whole thing? >> Me to validate her.
>> I might I might have to read the whole thing.
That seems kind of painful. I wish I was falling asleep with
it in Oh, his dick and m awkward, but it could be epic. Okay,
never mind then. Freak unmatched.
Maybe it was the strange carts. I don't know, man. I don't know
if kidnap is the right word. First screenshot here, she expresses
that she is a real freak and says that she wants me to kidnap
her, even saying, "I want to be tied up, taken to the woods,
and pounded, so maybe there's something wrong with me." I respond
by saying that we should not have in the woods,
dude, what?
Dude, what?
I just I Tom, I just want I want to like I want to be kidnapped
and taken to the woods and violated.
I don't think we should have in the woods to be honest. I don't
think that would be fun. I think I would get sticks and dirt
on my privates and that would not be fun. That would not be cool.
Okay. All right. >> And she says, "You nervous?" Right
here in this next one, Rowan says, "I yearn to be manhandled
and led across a dark room. That's why I like you." I reply saying,
"You are like a dungeon person." And she says, "You are big like
a caveman and I feel small next to you." In fact, anytime I wanted
to have more loving, slow, you know, um I guess sensual intercourse
with Rowan in the >> Yeah, it's hard. It's hard to know.
I think Tom has like talked like this. I think Tom basically
was on Discords when he was like 14. Okay. Like Tom comes from
the art commentary community. He was basically in these Discord
like communities for a long time. I think he talks like this.
Not really. Possibly not even because he's like not trusting.
I think he probably has seen enough like Discord log dump betrayals
that he might actually talk like this all the time no matter
what in DMs with anybody. Like he might just never DM anybody
as if they're like seeing into his soul like never be honest
with somebody. He probably is just always expecting these will
leak. Every single message I send online as if it's going to
leak to the public, right? So he gets like a little more explicit
sometimes, but it's all he's basically trying to protect himself
from being mocked online.
I I think that's like interesting and probably almost helped
him here. Almost certainly helped him here. But also feels really
sad that like he can't engage like himself. It feels like really
honestly like I don't know how
how do you have like a legitimate relationship with somebody
you can't if you especially a long-distance relationship
and you can't um ever express like how you feel or what you really
think? you nervous right here in this next one. Rowan says, "I
yearn to be manhandled and led across a dark room. That's why
I like you." I reply saying, "You are like a dungeon person."
And she says, "You >> the main character,
>> caveman, and I feel small next to you." In fact, anytime
I wanted to have more loving, slow, you know, um I guess sensual
intercourse with Rowan in the bedroom, she actually had a problem
with that. I remember one specific instance where I was being
more slow and and sensual and I remember her whispering in my
ear saying, "I want you to pound me." And that's probably why
on on June 5th, 2025, she texted me saying, "I need to get face
for an hour." And I replied by saying, "Damn, exams suck." On
June 7th, she text me and said, "For an hour." >> Wait,
hold on. Hypnotized by that. You give good head. I miss it. Yeah,
I need to get face for an hour. Damn, exams suck. and I replied
by saying, "Damn, exams suck." On June 7th, she >> very
cool. Very not. Yeah, he's a dude. He's not even a good chatbot.
He's not even a good chatbot at all. But again, I don't think
it's because he couldn't engage in this. I legitimately just
think it's because he is expecting this stuff to get leaked,
right?
That's what it is. He could probably engage with it in some way.
He just doesn't want to. He he probably almost feels baited.
>> I am excited to get borderline domestic violently. At
one point in the interview, she
says, "I'm >> sorry, I keep I'll be there at like 6:30ish.
Okay, so earlier." Yeah. Yeah. Excited to get borderline domestic
violently. Oh boy. >> Excited to get borderline domestic
violently. At one point in the interview, she states that one
time I was angry at my ex-girlfriend and that the next time we
had
>> He did hard it. He did hard it. He did hard it. He did
hard it. I think Tom kind of leans out of this and kind of says
it's like the girl who wants this. It's pretty obvious that this
is the thing he's into and that he gives signals
for this stuff like pretty consistently, right?
I I believe >> I believe that I was particularly aggressive.
This is a very strange thing to accuse me of given that on October
13th, Rowan says verbatim, "Sometimes I want to fight you just
so you be more angry when you me." She clarifies saying, "I do
>> some." She says something wrong again. >> You
like that though, even without the fighting. So, >> dude,
he's not reading the whole DMs every time. Yeah, be nice to me.
I'm a nice guy. That's some kind of some kind of loose screw
you got to screw in.
it does seem like he's actually saying in the DMs like, you know,
I
maybe No, maybe maybe you're going a little too far here. I h
do I believe it? Do I believe this? I almost believe
the opposite. I almost believe like he wants to lean into it
and he's saying this cuz he's he's again just concerned. He that's
that's the primary thing going on in his head. He's going to
leak someday. I'm not going to lean into any of this. I will
not be caught. I will not be caught. I will not be caught. >> So
at every opportunity, this girl is publicly saying, "Oh my god,
look at all this horrible he did to me." And then she's texting
me that she wants me to kidnap her, tie her up, and pound her
in the woods. And if anyone is putting up any resistance to that,
it's me. She once again lies about weird little things in the
interview. Um like like she says that I was her second >> Um
he was my
I guess my second boyfriend. >> And when I heard this,
I was very confused because she told me that I was her third.
In my opinion, she said this to make herself seem less experienced
than she really is. To make the case stronger that I was taking
advantage of her. Now, in this next post, she writes, "Again,
I'm not alleging anything illegal, just that he would hit and
choke because he was a super gooner. Sort of normalize it in
my head, but it's definitely not okay to do that." So, for information
on how I supposedly normalize this behavior, let's go back to
the beginning of our relationship and see what our conversations
about were like. On Wednesday, May 14th, after only hanging out
with Rowan once, she texted me saying she's excited to hang out
with me again. This is the part where I do think he handled sort
of the meat of the allegations coming from this person so far,
at least with regards to the illegal recording and the rough.
Okay, so now he is going to basically go and say like look at
who this person was when we first met.
And I usually don't like that or usually think it's like a problem,
but that's because a lot of times when I see responses, this
is like the meat of
speaking of meat, this is the meat of like someone's response.
will be like just trying to pick at the edges of like character
attacks and minor inconsistencies.
It feels less bad when he's already dealt with like the primary
pieces of the allegation to go and talk about some of this stuff.
>> And she already knows my is massive without me saying
anything to her at this point. So, as you might suspect, we did
have intercourse on our second date. And after this first encounter,
Rowan texts me saying, quote, "Thing is so hot. I never did that
before. you should tie me up next time. My response to this is
consensual is good. And she says, you
>> know what I meant by that? I don't know what to call
it. Now, this is maybe one of the more interesting ones. Okay,
so this one's one of the more interesting
because obviously he suggested something that they did and she
thought was hot that she is now calling thing, right?
Tom doesn't want
it to be called rap thing or it to be alleged in DMs that he
was, you know, forceful or rapey. So he says consensualism is
good. None of these guys could spell. By the way, all these guys
got on the internet too early. They didn't they didn't weren't
worried. Like Tom, I think by the time he was in college was
like already making a bunch of money on YouTube. None of these
guys can spell for and it's hilarious. Okay.
It's hilarious.
So, consensual is good. So, he obviously introduced some kind
of dynamic that's a little
rough, a little But we don't know what that is. So, I saw people
suggesting that this was him saying like we're like, "Oh, we're
going to do CNC on like a second date." I don't think that's
necessarily the case at all. Um, I don't think like you could
say it's rape play. This could be something really light. I'm
telling you, this could be something that's like not that crazy.
You really don't know without more details. Like she said this,
but then what did he say? Like was there any dynamic where he
was not where he said, "Well, I want you to start saying no.
Stop. No, stop." You don't know that,
right? That there's no reason to believe that they needed like
a safe word or some discussion first. Yeah. I don't know. People
are People are going way too buck wild on this one in a way that
I I think is totally inappropriate, right? Is choking. It's not
even necessarily that
what if he was like
what if he's having sex with this girl and he says he's like
holding her hands above her head or something. He's like, "You
should try to get away. Just try to get away right now." Like
what if what if it's just that? That's not that's not play,
right? That's like you could do a thing like that and if she
says stop, it still means stop. There's nothing changed there.
Right. So, I don't know. It's You don't really know what she's
referring to here. He It's something he introduced, but it could
be something that's totally appropriate on a second date to introduce.
Totally fine. Personally, I think so.
Do you just mean she's really inexperienced that she thinks relatively
No. No. I'm saying there are things that are fairly extreme or
might like put somebody off
that they could call thing that aren't necessarily like CNC,
something that needs to be negotiated. There are things you could
do here that you could negotiate in the middle of that would
be
anyway. So from the very first inter
>> but yeah it's it's some dynamic he introduced right
off the bat that she wasn't the one immediately introducing >> reaction
we have she calls our for some reason saying how hot it is to
which I clarify that it was consensual and she says I know what
you mean and for the record I never indulged in her fantasy to
be tied up just not something I was interested in in anyway uh
>> cuz that would require work >> and we also never
did anything in the woods in case you're curious >> anything
that requires work anything that isn't me just pounding away
at you from the comfort of my own bedroom. Anything beyond that,
you know? No, no, no, thank you. Or your bedroom, one of the
two. >> No, that's a lot of work. To hammer this point
home, let's go over some more text where Rowan talks about. On
Friday, May 16th, she texts me asking when I'm free and says
that she needs my quote big odd dick. And I say, "Don't say ah."
And she says, "It is, and I need it." On May 18th, Rowan says
she's not used to being with someone with as big of a dick as
mine. She said this. This is unrelated to any allegations, guys,
but I just needed to get it in here, okay? I just needed to get
it in here. I have a huge I have a huge I have a huge >> hurt,
but she wants to do it again and she won't be a about it. Some
of her public claims about me are more desperate and weird than
others. Um, like despite her acting like I am a like like degenerate,
uh, repeatedly doing she doesn't enjoy. Here she is saying, "You
match my freak kind of, not you're too freaky or we've been too
freaky." She says that I match her freak. Here in this next one,
she says, "I'm getting on my knees as soon as I see you." By
the way, freak mode. >> That's the That's the most he gives
in this entire dude was thinking about the just now.
>> You going to tear it up or what? Now my question for
you in the audience would be um do people who are into slow romantic
candle lit uh describe intercourse as they're getting torn up?
I would say probably not.
Yes. By the way, I don't know. Am I
am I crazy? People like different kinds of sex with the same
partner. You could do different kind, right? People like some
variety, dog. That's what she was asking you for, some variety.
Here in this next one, she says she's going to leave mass early
on Sunday to go get some. And keep in mind, I don't I don't want
to reveal any of this information, okay? I don't want to be saying
this. Uh I don't want to be here right now. Um and I would never
intend on shaming an exartner, but she's gone out of her way
to not only shame me, but also to lie in an effort to paint me
as some gooner freak borderline.
So, let's let's keep going here. Ran makes a post saying that
I am a Patrick Baitman Goonaron because I flexed in the mirror
after we had sex. But the the strange part about this is that
I have a text of her saying, quote, I keep thinking about how
hot it was watching myself take your big dick in the mirror.
Gunnar is sorry. Reading through what? Your honor,
she has unclean hands. She's also a Patrick Baitman Goonar, your
honor. She has unclean hands. She does the same thing I do. Yeah,
that wasn't like a that wasn't like counterproof or anything.
That was just, hey, this likes watching herself in the mirror,
too. >> What she says about me publicly,
>> this girl is an info. Um, maybe I think she's like into
him and knows that he likes having too. And they're long distance,
so she just keeps saying the same thing over and over again,
right? Not the same thing. She's saying different things, but
she's trying to like maintain some conversation,
>> asking me if I can if I can have >> But but hold
on. She might be like she is terminally online. She knew about
like Tom's videos,
right? She Oh, that hasn't come out yet. Don't worry, we'll get
to it. She's been terminally online, so she probably is some
kind of like gooner type person from these internet communities.
All right, seems to be the case a lot of the time. Here, I gotta
use the bathroom really quickly. I had to drank like a liter
of flu before I started stream. Okay, I'll be right back. I'm
going to let this play. I'll be right back. I rolled it back
a little bit. You just got to listen again. I'll be like 40
>> I missed that big so much. I'm under spells. On July
5th, I bring up us wearing condoms and Rowan says, "Ew, no."
And then tells me that she wants me to cream pie her and that
she's a real freak. After I say, "Happy birthday, sweetie." before
her 21st. She says that all she wants for her birthday is my
big
In this next one, she texts me saying, "I miss feeling like I'm
going to break in half. Not going to lie." In this next one,
she says, "I like when you make me choke on it and call me a
good girl." On July 23rd, she says, "Can I come over and suck
on it Friday night?" Which I don't accept. I tell her that I'm
busy. She then says, "I have the big white addiction." Interestingly
enough, in this next one, she's asking me if I can uh if I can
have sex with her while holding her in the air essentially and
tells me that I should try to do it. Once again, a pretty bizarre
thing to ask someone to do who allegedly has been abusing you
for 3 months by now with overly rough. On July 21st, she starts
off by texting me, I hate gooner men. And then not even one minute
later, she says, "I need that big white." On August 23rd, she
says, "Whenever I wake up without my morning Tom face, I am sad."
On September 2nd, she expresses that she wish she lived closer
to me, but if she did, it would be an issue because she would
want to come suck my dick all the time. On September 17th, she
sends me an Instagram reel of someone praying.
>> Uh, it is just all the hints, isn't it? And she follows
up by saying, "I miss that so much." Here in this next photo,
she user saying she's a good port. I don't even know if that's
the truth. There's like other things that could be going on here,
right?
There are other things that could be going on here. Like there
could easily be a thing going on here where like that's the kind
of stuff Tom responds to and she just wants conversation while
they're not talking and if she's just talking about like her
life or her problems possibly. We don't know the rest of the
DMs, right?
I don't know how much they talked honestly with the amount she's
like asking for and Tom is just like not responding. I'm curious
if she like did they really have a relationship but this is really
his girlfriend because later on in the text we'll see that he
says she's his girlfriend but I'm like dude you're like not having
you're like not I I don't see but maybe he's just putting this
stuff in here cuz it is all that's >> he sends me a picture
of her in lingerie with the caption when it's time and after
she said that all I did was respond with a photo of the movie
just friends on Thursday September 25th at 7:30 a.m.
When it's time
lingerie photo after she said that all I did was respond with
a photo of >> just just friends.
>> Jesus Christ, man. >> The movie Just Friends on
Thursday, September 25th at 7:30 a.m. Rowan says, "I hope you
come. I got something special for our times." I say, "Change
that to consensual encounters." And she says, "I know." She expands
on this particular message and says, "Are you mad at me? I know
it's consensual." So, even as we're approaching over four months
of being together, she's still telling me that our is consensual
and that she likes it. Now that I've gone through a lot of our
messages, I think it's pertinent that we get into the month of
October. This is the month that Rowan has publicly claimed there
was one specific incident that occurred during which she asked
me to stop having sex with her, and I did not. To be perfectly
clear, this never happened. But just to have some fun, we can
go through our text day by day in this month to see which day
this horrific incident could have possibly occurred. On October
2nd, she texts me saying, "You are perfect." on October 3rd and
4th we hung out. She asked me if I got home okay and she says
that I am her formal date in her heart. She then says that she
hates when anyone
Yeah. When so this I think October and the reason she thinks
that he was so rough during that session or whatever.
I think that's when the the hacking happens is sometime in October.
I think
because I think she said it was his response to that he was very
upset. No, no, no, no, no. It was a stream between Lyrics and
Kai. That's what made him really mad >> on her body. Even
in a positive way and I tell her that she should eat slop and
go for a walk and really trying to gain weight because I hate
when people talk about my body even in a nice way. It's just
weird as like would you ever tell a fat person how fat they are
but it's okay for people to come up to you and be like you're
so skinny so tiny.
>> Worry about it and that she is beautiful. On October
8th she continues
>> dude.
Dude,
says me if I
don't won't if I
something have violence very soon and it's anime girl in a
I don't maybe I can't I can't tell what this word is just in
general. When I think about you in a bikini or something, I feel
like a rabid dog. Maybe Tom is just really bad at this. I don't
know. I don't know, man. That's a that's a crazy picture for
a normal college girl to have. Okay. complimenting my arm. She
then resends me a meme that says, "Me if I do not have violence
very soon." On October 8th, she also says, "I miss my handsome
husband here." I tell her, "I landed in Texas." She says, "Uh,
I miss sucking on it." She then texts me saying, "You got to
start putting time in your reminders." On October 9th, she says
that she wants to hang out. I say, "I arrived." On October 10th,
she says, "Let me know when you get back safe. I always have
such a fun time with you." On October 14th, she says she wishes
she was waking up to me in the morning. And she then expresses
sadness that I'm not moving closer to uh the city where she's
from to live near her. Uh she then states that her
>> So this is around the time she goes or he moves, right?
And he moves to
Austin, it looks like to live with Brandon Buckingham. Okay.
Not so personal. Life is good. Be happy. Wait. Well, we'll still
see each other if I move there. I'm not dramatic, but please
don't move to Austin. I already know you will hate it. I hope
you get your video done. We're going to make it wherever. Do
you want to move there just because your friend is moving there?
No, it'll be fine. I think positively, not negatively. Happy
things. I'm thinking positively, but I don't want you to live
four hours away from me. Lol. I love you, Tom. >> Listen,
I'm not moving closer to uh the city where she's from to live
her. Uh she then states that her life has improved since meeting.
>> Hope you make the right decision. I'm looking I'm hoping
my soul and cheek go down. I look like Quagmire, Tom. Lol. I
think this must be after her wisdom teeth surgery, right? What
happened? Did you irritate it? Seems like this place did a bad
job.
P did not did it. Not surprised. Jesus.
The women in Texas be racist, dog.
What the hell, man? What the I I don't know. I just woke up with
half my face swollen. It's nice that last semester I was getting
drunk every weekend and now instead I spend quality movie time
with my pooky. Good change. I would say that is a better use
of time. No cap for sure. Not to blaze, but my life has improved
since meeting you. Me? Mine too. because previously she was partying
and going out and now she spends time with me. On October 15th
she says, "I started my period. I wish I could come suck on it."
Uh, and that evening she says, "I would killed myself if I had
to talk to any other man but you." I say, "That's true. I'm a
nice guy." And she says, "Yeah, I'm the bad guy." On October
17th, we've already read this, but this is once again where she
says, "Do you ever go back and watch our videos?" And I say,
"Yeah, I do sometimes, actually." and she responds to me that
she's thinking about that right now and says, "Need that big
white in the mirror. You dead ass look like the Hulk compared
to me." Now, one thing to note here is that at no point does
she express that the videos were taken without her consent. Once
again, I just want to I just want to have that hammered down
here. On October 19th, she texts me saying she needs my milk
right now. She then says, "I miss my perfect jacked boyfriend."
And that night, she sends me nudes. Uh at 10 p.m., she sends
me a photo.
I feel like saying the soft A in DMs is less than Pidgeet. I
feel like PET is just a slur. Soft A has positive connotations.
And I don't even think she wasn't using it negatively. Pit is
just like a straight up slur >> of a guy with a clock in
his hand and says, "I need that dick." Uh on October 21st, I
sent her a bicep photo. She responds saying, "You look good,
Tom. I can't wait to suck your dick." Uh she says, "I love you.
You're a great boyfriend." She then says, "You never officially
asked me to be your girlfriend." To which I say that we did.
on October 23rd. There's proof we hung out that day. She then
says, "Text me when you get home safe." And I say, "I made it."
She
So, I'd say, "So far, I don't I understand what he's going for,
but he already admitted that this isn't necessarily the case,
right? So, he he already said once in this video that just because
you're abusive doesn't mean like women will stay with abusive
partners. That is something that can happen, not just women.
People will stay with abusive partners." And then he's going
through this and he's basically showing like when could I have
been abusive. Here's all of these texts where she really likes
me. And it's like, well, I don't know. I don't know what the
precise date is, right? We could probably lock it down if we
figured out from Lyric's stream when Kai was on cuz I do believe
it's a Kai Lyric
if I remember correctly. A Kai Lyrics collaboration that made
Tom really angry. That's what she says, right? So, we could try
to find that, but he's basically just showing like that she liked
him or was was being nice in DMs.
Not necessarily like disproving anything, just sort of a lot
of proof that they were for for his perception they could have
been in a very good >> He also texted me saying, "I love
when my bed smells like your musk." On October 24th, she says,
"Good night. You're the best boyfriend ever." October 25th, she
sends me a photo of herself in a deer outfit and says, "Meow.
I miss Tom's big white." That night, she says, "I'm going to
send you pics tomorrow." on October 26th. We've read this one
before, but here she says, "Next time during our epic time, you
can tie me up." I say, "You mean consensual?" And she follows
it up by saying, "Dude, dude, no, you don't just say that. You
actually explicitly say, do not text me saying epic time,
consensual time. I'm also excited to wear our costumes." Okay,
dude.
He's just consistently every time that word comes up, he's like,
"Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope. Don't call it that. Don't call
it that. Don't call it that. I'm not I'm not on the record with
that. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope.
>> Yep. I say, "You mean consens?"
>> Why is this dude so paranoid about his text getting
leaked? Uh, he does get into that. There is a reason he he is
paranoid about this. And he actually waits a long time to reveal
it. Okay.
It also makes it weird that this went so long and was so I don't
know. I don't know. Parts of this were very weird to >> Sex
and she follows it up by saying, "You know what I mean, Tom?
rough. Once again, these are really weird messages. And she God,
he always goes, "I'll listen. I'm in the car and she's playing
Drake. Nice."
>> You know what I mean, Tom? Rough. Once again, these
are really weird messages to be sending to someone that you now
claim is abusing you on a weekly basis. Now, that evening, the
evening of October 26th, we can see that I hang out at Rowan's
house and I sleep over. Then, there's a text that shows that
I'm leaving uh and mentioned that I took my friend to the hospital.
Uh on October 27th, she says that she hopes I'm doing well. She
loves me so much. October 30th. She says that we'll be married
in two years. October 31st at 12. He loves me so much. October.
Uh, going to spread some misinformation, JK. But I'm excited.
We're going to hang out soon anyway. Don't even consider that.
We're going to hang We're going to get married in 2 years, Tom.
Yes. Yes. I'm joking. Good. And epic. I'm putting tinsel in my
hair. Why so serious? Hello.
Who sends the next message on October 30th? That's what I want
to know. >> 30th. She says that we'll be married in two
years. October 31st.
I had a nightmare. You broke up with me.
The bad dreamy. Well, that not
Okay. Happy Halloween. Going to make a spooky jello. >> At
12:30 in the morning, she texts me and says, >> "Okay,
I had an >> I I can't imagine talking like this when you
broke up with me. Oh my god." Uh, she then says that I should
cut a hole in my Batman suit for my dick. On October 31st in
the afternoon, she says, "Oh, Tom, I yearn for the big white."
On November 1st at 1:20 a.m., she says, "Up. No, good night.
I love you." Yeah, it's over. I tell her that I'm falling asleep.
And she says, "You was mad,
>> Oh, no. >> In love with her and not me. I'm going
to myself. I tell her, "Good night. I'll see you." And she says,
"You
you was madly in love with her and not me. I'm going to kill
myself. Good night, Rowan. See you tomorrow."
Don't say everything like that ever >> And not me. I'm
going to myself. I tell her, "Good night. I'll see you tomorrow.
And I then say, "Do not say anything like that ever again." Now,
for a little more context on this specific message and what she's
talking about here, uh, during our entire relationship, she was
extremely insecure about the fact that before I was with her,
I had lived with a girl. Uh, and she wanted me to basically show
more commitment in the relationship than I was willing to show
as far as like moving physically.
>> Yeah. I think that's the issue I'm seeing here. She's
giving like a lot of signals and Tom is happy with all of the
attention that he gets from somebody who's giving those signals,
but he doesn't want to give anything back. And instead of saying,
"No, I don't see it that way. No, like this isn't very serious.
No, like I this isn't serious to me, like I don't think we're
going in that direction," instead of being honest about the way
he feels, he wants to keep farming the one-sided attention, the
love he gets from her without giving any of it back. Right. Like
that's that's how it looks to me. Again, not a crime, just being
like a person.
But that is what it looks like to me is she she very clearly
is going in one direction. He's going in the other direction.
And he can't just say that. He's not just saying it, right? I
was with her. I live with a girl.
>> Don't be gay.
Hold on. No, no, no, no, no. It's not being gay. It's about being
the person who's not emotionally involved in the relationship.
You can just respond.
No, no, no, no, no. You're You're actually wrong. It's not always
on her.
It's not always on the other per the person who's like obsessed
with the relationship. You You can't just say, "Well, you know,
everybody's an adult here. That person clearly isn't seeing things
clearly, and you're taking advantage of the fact. You're very
aware that they're not seeing things clearly because you see,
and you're offput by how they're seeing things. You are the person
who has a lens into your own thoughts on their messages. you
are the person who can inform her and you don't want to do that
because it would be awkward because you like the fact that this
girl whenever you go to wherever she is, she'll like [__]
you. She'll let you do whatever you want, right? That's what
you want.
And as long as you don't explicitly dash that hope, this is like
everybody would get this totally if it was a woman taking advantage
of a guy in the friend zone, right? Every single person would
get that that like, oh, you know, continue to string this guy
along. ever say like kind of know that he wants a relationship
or he wants something more and you keep stringing him along to
take advantage of all the stuff he'll do for you, right? Everybody
would get it in that situation. Why don't you get it in this
situation? It's the same concept, right? If this was some guy
who some girl was like, "Well, you know, maybe we could go hang
out and watch a movie. Can I bring a friend?" Like, every single
person would get it. But because it's Tom and because it's a
girl,
you guys are like resistant to this. It's obviously true that
he knows that he's not as into it as she is. She's talking about
getting married. He doesn't even he's he's not remotely on uh
on that wavelength. Right.
It's become more obvious as they've gone along. Maybe he was
a little more serious at some point and then it kind of fell
off. right
now. I think the good thing the good thing for Tom to do would
be to communicate his thoughts on this that he doesn't want this
that it's not going in the direction she thinks and he's
like we we just want different things from this relationship.
I'm sorry it's not working out right.
Never seen a woman do that. Didn't realize that was a thing.
That's definitely a thing. Um
so I think Tom is like holding her at a distance trying to keep
her like obsessed with him. giving it back enough. Like he goes
on the Halloween date. I don't know. Like, by the way, he might
not even he might not be perceiving this. Maybe he's just not
old enough. He hasn't had enough experience yet. Maybe he's not.
But that's in essence what is happening. Even if it's not his
explicit drive to do it, it that is what's happening here, right?
Is this girl wants to be with him permanently and he's not interested
in it. And maybe he's unaware of that, but he should know that
this will blow up fairly predictably when this happens. like
when you are leading essentially leading somebody on even without
intending to you will have things up like this. Yeah. I mean
uh anac you can you could say this right but she doesn't see
it that way and if you want to be a good person if you're going
to Catholic mass because you want to be a good person
then you should be letting this person know that they're not
going to get the thing they want out of this relationship. You
should not lead them on. And he is leading her on. Yes. going
on dates with her, um, letting her say, "We're going to get married."
And he's like, "Yeah, that's cool." Right? Not correcting that.
Not explicitly saying, "No, I'm we're not getting married. No,
that's never happening." Right? That is leading her on. 100%
it is. And I've never once say heard him say like, "No, no, no,
that didn't happen." And now in the DMs, you see that she's talking
about it and he's not saying no to that. And I don't I don't
believe for a second based on the way he's texting and responding
that he actually thinks that. There's no indication here that
he has like a deeper concern or care for this person that would
lead you to believe they're going to get married one day. Zero.
I've not seen a single thing. Except maybe.
I I can't remember if he went over this or not yet, but maybe
the stuff around the eating disorder that he does show concern
there, but other than that, I I'm just not really seeing it.
>> Uh, and she wanted me to basically show more commitment
in the relationship than I was willing to show as far as like
moving physically closer to her.
Yeah. Oh man, you're you're just not getting it.
Um, an
it. This person might not be able to perceive this, right? They
love this person. They love Tom. They're obsessed with him. They
can't perceive that he is not that he's giving off those signals,
right? There's only one side of this that is perceiving things
accurately. It is incumbent on them to do it. Can we ever cancel
the person who doesn't? No. But I will always look at that person
very suspiciously. like you are a bad person if you're going
to consistently take advantage of somebody who can't see the
situation correctly obviously. So, and at a few points she suggested
that we move in together and I said, you know, it's just too
soon. We're not really ready for that. Um I I don't I don't think
that makes sense after dating for just a few months to move in
together. So, that's the context of this. She would constantly
bring up and compare herself to my ex or partners in general,
but my ex-girlfriend and and I was like, "Don't say stuff like
that. Like, I'm I'm dating you right now. Stop worrying about
this." So later on in the night, she texts me saying, "Mass is
needed. I am such a >> By the way, it's also possible that
Tom like just has trust issues and he does feel like he likes
this person. Maybe in person he's way different and that's like
we're just getting super different vibes from in person versus
the text. Maybe he's just like so by Discord leaks and that he
can't connect to a person via text that he's just like got so
many concerns. He's so paranoid about it." That's possible, right?
right? That he's giving off totally different vibes in the text
versus when they're meeting in person. But then that's that's
going to be rough. Like you're going to you're obviously going
to make somebody insecure when you respond this way. I think
almost anybody would be made insecure if their partner responded
to them this way consistently.
>> You know what I mean? I I don't know what normal person
wouldn't be made insecure if the person they were in love with
responded to them like this.
>> It's just it's very clear to me that that is what would
happen naturally. You're sending like a bunch of stuff. They're
basically giving you two three-word responses to >> a sweet
girl and have love in my heart for you. I know this. And this
carries into the morning where she says, "Hi, my sweet love."
The next day around noon, she says, "Sorry for being kind of
[__] Let me know when you're on your way." I say
that I've arrived. We take a photo in our Halloween outfits.
And on November 2nd, I say that I made it home. And she says
that she hopes that I have a good day. So, we've now made it
through the entire month of October, and there's no indication
of any kind of abuse, any kind of mistreatment, or even really
anything negative. But almost every single day, she says something
about how she loves me, how I'm perfect, how everything is good.
And she keeps sending me stuff the entire time without me even
asking. At the risk of belaboring the point, I do want to go
through a few more messages just for the hell of it, just so
I can confidently show that she was extremely the entire time
and never expressed any reservations about the sex we were
>> It's also to have these kinds of conversations over
text message. I mean, you could say that. I
I don't really like
why why do you care? I don't think so. Everybody else sound like
cringey. I don't think it's weird to do it to be honest. Yeah,
I don't think it's I don't think it's weird to do it at all.
>> On Wednesday, November 5th, out of nowhere, she texts
me saying, "I'm trying to make you nut." I just don't respond.
On December 12th, she sends me nudes again. Kind of a weird thing
to send to someone who apparently has blackmail on you again,
is it not? On December 24th, she says that I am a sweetie pie.
She's grateful for me. She wants to make me uh nut again in her
words and she hopes we're married for a long time. On January
2nd, she sends me a naked photo of herself again unprompted.
And the morning of January 8th, uh Rowan texts me saying that
before she comes to visit me, she needs to know that my dick
is working. Less than 36 hours later
that before she comes to
>> brother, this is crazy. Before I come to visit you in
a few days, I need to know that everything is working and I also
won't be interacting with your friend because it's supposed to
be just be us when I take time to come visit my friend. Yes.
Yes.
Oh, she doesn't like
What? What friend? I don't know what friend. I don't know what
you're referencing. Brandon, I don't care if you hang out with
him, but like just us when I come, please.
Oh, she doesn't like That makes the Brandon doxing way weirder
now. That makes it way weirder
that like they had beef.
That makes it way weirder to me.
I don't want you to hang out with this dude when I come and visit.
That's in January, by the way. >> Yeah. Isn't Brandon dying
at this time? Isn't Brandon literally in like a hospital bed
at this time?
>> H visit me. She needs to know that my dick is working.
Less than 36 hours later, I broke up with her. So, as you can
see,
the texts don't lie. Rowan was blatantly the more in the relationship.
I produced evidence of this. >> Wait, did he say it was
working?
>> He did not >> nearly every single week. and she
didn't produce any because there isn't any. But apart from the
idea that I filmed her without her consent and apart from the
idea that I was a abusive partner, she actually made some other
claims as well. So another claim she made is that I encouraged
her eating disorder. >> Um yeah, he would I told him very
early on like, hey, like I've struggled with eating issues in
the past and I'm kind of still trying to gain some weight and
make sure everything's okay. And he would tell me, oh, I love
how skinny you are. I like how >> why is she asking if
his is working? Um, one of the things when they went to Massachusetts
together, one of the things she said was that the entire time
that when they were in m Massachusetts, he couldn't get his card.
So, they didn't have sex at all and that she didn't like that.
>> Small you are, you know, like I love how your body is
like skinny and like just say all this stuff that was incredibly
hard to hear. This is also a pretty serious claim and if true
would undoubtedly make me a pretty up guy, but it's just not
true. Here, I directly discourage her eating disorder, even giving
her advice on gaining weight. And I say, "Starving yourself is
very bad for you." This next screenshot, she says she used to
be thick, but she self- nuked. I say, "You look the same, more
or less. I guess you lost some weight, but I think both are attractive."
This next one, she says that she feels skinny fat. I say I don't
agree. And I say that working out is good. And this next one,
she sends me an image that says nothing tastes as good as skinny
feels. And I say that's a sickening image. Now, for those who
don't know, this is like like I'm
again, that's just another allegation she's made that I feel
like is just totally nuked. Like it's totally gone, right? Like
it's
like she alleged that he was
celebrating andor pushing her towards this eating disorder and
it's just explicitly categorically disproven.
Like I I have a hard time putting into words because I'm not
sure I've seen like an online allegation get this harshly debunked
ever in the entire time I've been streaming. I'm trying to think
of one that was like this destroyed
and I can't actually think of one. Maybe there is one, but there's
just nothing like this. It's but that's because there's no reason
to make allegations like this when you when you're soed over
by the text with the person, right? Huge to null and KF. Honestly,
I mean, maybe to Null. Null really hates Tom for some reason.
I don't know why Tom Sorry, I don't know why Null hates Tom so
much to be honest with you.
I actually don't I have no idea cuz he really he really hates
Tom.
And he went and like talked to those dudes. Oh yeah, by the way,
that was
I I maybe I should have done something about that null picture
being on screen, but it's that was like Yeah. No got personally
involved was too geared to close the case. Yes, he got he got
personally involved and he was just like farming and mining for
all the personal details he possibly could, right? Cuz Tom left
him for I don't I don't see that either. I thought Tom got them
both on a call together.
Pulcarians and Ukrainians never get
>> Like a It's like a pro-anorexia slogan, I guess you
would call. >> Oh, right. This is actually the reason that
Tom consistently
he consistently like takes material from KF and never cites KF.
So he's got a whole bunch of like KF like videos that are essentially
just the KF thread for the person researched
that he's used their m material archived on Null's website to
make his videos for a very long time and he has never ever ever
like sourced them correctly or he's almost never sourced them
correctly. That's what it actually is. Sorry. That is why null
doesn't like Tom or why he has a problem with him now. Okay,
call it. Here in this next screenshot, she asked me if I'd still
like her if she gained weight. And I say yes. Here in this next
one, I tell her explicitly she should eat more food and drink
protein shakes to gain weight. And I also tell her that gaining
weight would be healthy for her, as well as saying, "I just want
you to be healthy." Here in this next one, I tell her that I
find her how she is, but that it could be healthy for her to
gain 5 to 10 lbs. So, this is now seven instances of me actively
discouraging her eating disorder despite her lying and saying
that I was egging it on. Now, one of the other allegations that
Rowan has levied towards me is that I'm into age play. She's
not alleging that I did it with her. She's alleging that I did
it with another girl named Ellie, who I briefly talked to 2 years
ago. Now, okay, this is like this is kind of the big one that
Tom's friends said they totally disavow him for. So, while this
is actually not even
like a criminal allegation, it's not even something that would
make him evil, a bunch of his friends said that they would essentially
never interact with him again if this came out and was true.
Now, I happen to believe this is true, that he's into some stuff
around this.
And I don't know if I I can't recall I'm not sure I watched the
section of the video, actually. I must have stopped before this.
So, I pretty much believe this is like a thing that's true. I
think there's a lot of anecdotal evidence around the edges that
it's true. I just personally don't think it's a problem if somebody
only engages with adult partners and what they do in like the
um No, no, no. He's like the older person in this. They only
engage with adult partners and they do it in like the comfort
of their own bedroom. I don't actually give a to be honest with
you. If that's like the kind of thing you're into, just whatever
or if your partner's into that and you indulge it. I just don't
I don't to me it's like not a big problem as long as you can
separate it, right? and you have the self-disipline to separate
it and not talk about it publicly. If you were also if you were
to talk about it publicly, I I think that would be a problem
for me, right? And like sort of like endorse a lifestyle that
I I I think when you're willing to keep it totally private, that
shows that you have a solid disconnect between like fantasy and
reality that you don't need to talk about that publicly that
you've got like self-control. And I'm not concerned that you're
going to dip into the pool of actual children
or I'm not as concerned as somebody who will talk about it publicly
all the time. Okay. So, while I think it's true, we'll see exactly
what he's going to prove out here cuz ultimately the picture
he pulled up >> that Rowan has levied towards me is that
I'm into age play. She's not alleging that I did it with her.
She's alleging that I did it with another girl named
So this girl, this is probably
honestly one of the more adult pictures you could find of her.
Like this is her looking old,
okay, from her Instagram. Like there are some other pictures
where she is like doing filters and stuff and she's looking like
very young. Okay.
Two years ago. Now there's no proof that I did anything close
to age play, but I did text her about these allegations.
>> Uh I mean I don't really want to po my to post it on
my story. I don't feel like coming back to social media right
now. But you have never done age play. Lol. You don't have to
post yourself or whatever. It's fine. I'm sorry you're going
through this whole thing. Would prefer if you could get a couple
people to could get people to like leave me the out of it. We
barely dated. I'm going to try my best to minimize you even being
talked about. Yeah. I mean, he told the he told the girl, the
Sacramento girl that he never hung out with this person, that
this person weirded him out, by the way. And now she's saying
we barely dated. Yeah. Now she's saying we barely dated. So
things are on that front.
On that front, people are getting Yes. 67. I see it. We on that
front. We're getting actually he was more into this girl than
anybody had expected or anybody believed up until now. It's actually
getting worse. He's being dragged further in. >> And she
clearly states that I've never done age play. An ex-girlfriend
of mine named Kai who I dated for 3 years also publicly posted
on Twitter saying that I never abused her. >> It was clear
I just can't say from my experience that it was ever nature.
Uh okay, whatever. I I feel like Kai did the age stuff to be
honest with you.
I think so. I think she basically personally and I I have no
proof of this and I would never say somebody has to cancel Tom
or anything like that. I get the impression that she just came
out and outright lied in her little document because that works
out better for her. She wants to start streaming. Uh Larry doesn't
want any of the smoke from Tom's community.
Right. I I'm pretty confident there are like a couple there were
some fake DMs which made it seem like it's it's the waters are
muddied, but I do believe there's a a DM where Smeaggle
talks about her regressing to like a 12-year-old or something.
Did Did Smaggle ever address that, by the way? That not a DM.
Um I think it's tweets, public tweets. Did Smaggle ever address
that? Did we ever figure out what that was about? No. Tom told
the girl in DMs
Destiny is 17. Uh, you say, "What do you mean the other girl
said Tom did age play with the young-looking girl, not that they
never dated?" No, she said Tom told her, and she showed DMs that
that prove this, that he was like, "Uh, yeah, this girl weirded
me out. I didn't even I couldn't be around her. She like really
weirded me out." Basically saying, "I didn't do anything with
her." That's what Tom said to her. And she showed DMs to that
effect. So, he just lied about how close he was to
>> yeah, I think the trans
age play. So, this brings the total counter up to five people.
Rowan, Katie, Ellie, Kai, and another random girl I banged a
year ago named Maddie, who for some reason came out in the midst
of all of this to post pictures of herself in my Now, this is
a weird one again, when this person posted, and again, it's it's
just weird to me because he's posting this person's full face.
I don't know if you can see it through Yeah, you can see it through
my avatar. Okay. Um,
here's this.
This is a person who posted with her face blacked out and Tom
is now putting her full face in his video.
Now, I I feel like he's saying if you say, "Fuck my privacy,"
then your privacy, right? But I don't think that's an acceptable
thing when you're a big YouTuber. Especially because this person
didn't reveal anything damning about him except maybe that he
did coke.
She basically was like, "Yeah, I dated Tom once. Also, he loved
Coke and then she dipped out and deleted her account. So, yeah,
this is like the weird self-defense doc. It's It is It is odd
that he would post her face in the video to be honest with you.
Uh like I I think this was wrong of her to do to him with no
serious allegation to be like, "Hey, I [__] this
guy and I'm making it public, you guys, and I'm I'm leaking some
personal details about him." I do think that's weird of her to
do, but I don't think an appropriate response to that is, "Oh,
I'm going to post your face now." the the picture you put it
at censored with your face like cropped out with your face like
scratched out. You know, I'm gonna actually post that full picture.
I think that's an inappropriate response personally. So, it is
what it is. Do you hang out with Masterson and not do Coke? I
have no idea. But that is where he did Coke provably before.
>> I have, by the way, that was just known from way before
this because uh Boax talked about it. Bo Black leaked that a
long time ago that him, Tom, Dick Mastersonson, and Veto did
coke in in like Barbie mansion in the be in the Hollywood Hills,
right? Like he Bo
say that I never was into this fetish with them. The closest
thing I've ever engaged in when it comes to age play is that
um sometimes girls do call me daddy
it's a little embarrassing given that I
>> um me. I I you know I I accept that it's it's something
people are going to see is a little bit strange. Um
bro, imagine being like in such a like moral frog position that
you have to be like yeah uh sometimes I get girls to call me
daddy during and I know that that's like really weird guys. I
know that that's really weird and totally outside of the norm
and I I'm I get it. Okay. I get All I can really do at this point
is accept that it's something that I've done. And I think that
Rowan should accept it about herself, too, given that she also
called me daddy during and over text repeatedly. >> No,
that's not what he said. He said sometimes girl girls call me
daddy. That's what he said. I'm inferring that he likes that
and pushes them in that direction because
because of the other dude, it's like implied. I am literally
inferring this. Sometimes girls do call me daddy during
>> That's not weird. That's not weird. Women do that. The
problem is the only reason that that would be weird is if you
encourage or like it or ask them to do it more.
Somebody else doing an action is not weird on his part,
right? It's not. It's just not weird on his part at all if other
people are saying that to him.
I think personally what I what I see this as from my point of
view is him saying um yeah I kind of like that and I want them
to do that obviously and that's the weird part. That's that's
very clear to me to be honest. >> Uh it's a it's a little
embarrassing given that I am um me I I you know I I accept that
it's it's something people are going to see is a little bit >> Yeah,
that's that's what I'm saying. Pilking tongue is that I think
I think he
asked for that or baits it or
I I personally believe that if girls weren't doing it automatically
he'd be the one introducing it and that's why he's saying it's
weird
cuz he knows that he's being a bit weird,
right? Otherwise, if it was just other girls saying it, it wouldn't
be weird. Um, all I can really do at this point is accept that
it's something that I've done and I think that
>> something that I've done. You've had you've other girls
All I can do is accept that it's something I've done. What did
you do? You just said other girls call you that. What do you
mean something you've done?
>> I'm going into this fetish with them. The closest thing
I've ever engaged in when it comes to age play is that um sometimes
girls do call me daddy during
it's a it's a little embarrassing given that I am um me. I I
you know I I accept that it's it's something people are going
to see is a little bit strange. Um all I can really do at this
point is accept that it's something that I've done and I think
that Rowan
something that I've done
right. I fully believe he just asked them to call him or he
I I I think so. I think so.
Anyway, okay. I'm I'm pretty sure I feel very confident on that
actually, which by the way, I wouldn't even say that's weird.
I don't I don't care personally. You're allowed to ask for what
you want. That's just facts. Okay. You're allowed to ask for
what you want from an adult who you have an inc a consensual
relationship with. Okay? You can do whatever the [__]
you want. I don't care. I think it's weird to judge him as >> accepted
about herself too given that
I think it's weird to judge him as I guess only in so far as
weird as like outside of the norm like outside of the normal
two standard deviations of the normal distribution. Okay. No,
it's not. It's like um
it's it's average enough that it's >> also called me daddy
uh during and over text repeatedly. In the same vein as this
accusation, Rowan stated, "One more thing to add I thought was
odd. never really expressed any interest in Hello Kitty or that
type of e-girl stuff, but I had like one Hello Kitty figure in
my car. As a gift, Tom bought me Hello Kitty pajamas and a bunch
of Hello Kitty stuff. So, Rowan essentially wants you to believe
that I'm put. >> You just said he was weird for being called
daddy.
No, I didn't. And I'm actually super confused how you could take
what I said as that. >> Hello Kitty on to her as if I have
some kind of weird fascination with it. But the truth is that
I am a 23-year-old man and I don't give a [__] about
Hello Kitty. Okay. The only reason I bought her anything Hello
Kitty themed at all, which was once, by the way, was because
she frequently expressed interest in it. Here she is sending
me a photo, which Hello. Wait, what did he get? >> The
only reason I bought her anything Hello Kitty at all, which was
once.
>> What did he buy? Chromium plush women's pajama pant,
black, small collectibles. Chrommy bedding super soft cozy decorative
cuddle pillow. Fast forward. Komi reusable nonwoven shopping
tote bag, large, purple.
Wow. By the way, was because she frequently expressed interest
in it. Here she is sending me a photo with a Hello Kitty figurine
next to her printer. Here she is sending me a photo with a handdrawn
and colored Hello Kitty image on her >> handdrawn and colored
bro. That's like bead art, isn't it? That's like the bead art
stuff. I think those are beads.
But yeah, there's Hello Kitty stuff there. There's um Komi. I
I think that's Komi. We just saw Chromi on the previous page,
right? More kind of Hello Kitty. That's the uh Moka thing. I
think that's a dog from Adoka.
>> Yeah, she made these for here. In regards to her decorating
my room, she says, "No hello Kitty with a frowny face." And I
say, "Correct." And something interesting about these texts is
that she shows that she has a poster of the movie Lolita on her
wall. >> Dude, I'll
Jay is misaned.
Just tipped five. Let me get this straight. Out of everything
claimed, the worst he actually did was ask her to call him daddy.
Are we for real right now, Jay? >> I'm a misanderist. Why
am I a misandress? I literally said I would not cancel or professionally
disassociate from Tom for those allegations as they came out.
I thought people weren't standing up business there. I thought
there was no significant proof behind some of the things being
said, and I evaluated the evidence as it came out. I was on Tom's
side.
I was on Tom's side more than his long-term friends.
Okay, out of here. Also, yeah, I don't know how you call me misandress.
Also, are these edited?
Am I Am I crazy? Am I hallucinating?
Like,
or are these just really tilted from the ceiling?
I feel like the ceiling's going this direction, and these aren't
tilted to go along with the ceiling at all, but I can't tell.
Am I like,
is there some perspective here I'm not understanding? Like, it
feels like there's just some perspective here I'm not understanding.
like this.
This looks edited.
Say hi to Miz. What's up, Miz? How's it going? Wait, Miz was
here. I didn't see Miz in the chat if he was here. If he's watching.
Oh, you want to play in our wild guild with us? Oh, I missed
this. Yeah. Yeah, probably.
Maybe. Maybe. I don't know. I will have to see how much. Maybe.
Definitely. Maybe. But this mostly I I want to. It would be mostly
the WoW thing I'm not sure about. I definitely want to play though.
My my audience wants me to play, too. I'll I'll DM him in case
he he might not have seen the message. I was going off on this
Turkey tom thing. So, yeah, maybe I I'll say yes. I'll give you
a yes. I'll commit to it. Actually, I'll straight up commit right
now. You make a Wow Guild, I'll play.
Okay, I'll do it. I'll do it. I don't know if he saw it. I was
I was going off and I missed them his DM. Okay, well, we're going
to continue.
Sorry, man. We're very important. We're trying to figure out
whether or not this is edited. Is it edited?
Hm. I wonder what the movie Lolita could possibly be about. This
film is about a middle-aged professor who is attracted to adolescent
girls he calls Nyfetts. He rents a room in the house of a young
widow to get closer to her 14-year-old daughter, Dolores Hayes
Low, whom he calls Lolita. Obsessed with the girl, he eventually
gains control over her after he takes her cross country with
him. Rowan even says that I should watch this movie, to which
I reply that I feel like it's a movie adult men aren't supposed
to see. In this next screenshot, Rowan asks me, "If I start dressing
like a weird Hello Kitty egirl, would you still with me?" And
I replied, "No, I don't want you to do that. I find it kind of
repulsive." Here, Rowan is texting me upset that she has to take
down all of the Hello Kitties from her dorm room. And this next
one is probably the strangest reference to Hello Kitty out of
all of them. Here, she's sending So, suffice to say, she said
she has no interest in this kind of thing. She'd never shown
And that's just not true. She's shown a bunch of interest.
We know that's not likely not her room. It's her friend's room.
The previous image in the video has uh in the video has her room.
Well, hold on. Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Um h
wall here. Is this Huh? I can't tell.
My rooms tend to be like that. Inspo. Oh, it's No, it's literally
not her room. It She literally says inspo.
Am I I can't be the only person who knows what inspo means. I
didn't read that cuz Tom didn't read that. Yeah, it's obviously
not her room.
Is inspo.
Inspo means like inspiration, right? As in this is something
I want. This is something I'm trying to manifest now.
JK, but probably like Legos and car stuff. I don't know what
men like.
Help me. No Hello Kitty stuff though.
Inspo. I think she's poking fun at the idea that he's into girls
who act young. That's what she's doing, right? She's like poking
fun at him.
I think that's what is happening here is she she's taking that
idea. I can't remember when. Did he say when this these texts
are? Hold on. That's definitely what she's doing. >> Hello
Kitty figurine next to her printer. Here she is sending me a
photo with a handdrawn and colored Hello Kitty image on her wall
as she made these herself. Here in regards to her decorating
my room, she says, "No hello Kitty." with a frowny face. And
I say, "Correct." And something interesting about these texts
is that she shows that she has a poster of the movie Lolita on.
This is how much attention Tom's paying to this woman's texts
overall. Okay. is he straight up
he straight up
isn't paying enough attention to realize that this is an inspiration
picture. He's like super not caring about the things that get
sent here.
Um I
I'll be real and I I'm going to go even
If it came out that he was cheating and he's like managing multiple
relationships here at the same time, I wouldn't be shocked at
all. He's got so little time to talk to this person. He's like
so checked out of these conversations.
I I just wouldn't be shocked at all if you other people, right?
How do you not see that on a second look? I don't know. I don't
know. That's not even meant to be her thing here. And I wouldn't
be shocked if it's edited. It literally says inspo right there.
You don't even need to go figure it out where it's from. It's
just obviously not her room.
She's saying, "Yeah, this is this is what I think your room's
going to be decorated like." He's literally memeing. She's literally
memeing on him. >> I'll be honest. One of the first times
outside of this text that she's shown any personality whatsoever.
So, that's kind of interesting. >> Hm. I wonder what the
movie Lolita could possibly be about. This film is about a middle-aged
professor who is attracted to adolescent girls he calls Nymph
Fetts. He rents a room in the house of a young widow to get closer
to her 14-year-old daughter, Dolores Hayes Low, whom he calls
Lolita. Obsessed with the girl, he eventually gains control over
her after he takes her cross country with him. Rowan even says
that I should watch this movie to which I reply after.
She says no Hello Kitty with a frowny face when I say correct.
And something interesting about these texts is that she shows
that she has a poster of the movie Lolita on her wall. Hm. I
wonder what the movie Lolita could possibly be about. This film
is about a middle-aged professor who is attracted to adolescent
girls he calls nyfetts. He rents a room in the house of a young
widow to get closer to her 14-year-old daughter, Dolores Hayes
Low, whom he calls Lolita. Obsessed with the girl, he eventually
gains control over her after he takes her cross country with
him. Rowan even says that I should watch this movie, to which
I reply that I feel like it's a movie adult men aren't supposed
to see. In this next screenshot, Rowan asks me, "If I start dressing
like a weird Hello Kitty egirl, would you still with me?" And
I replied, "No, I don't want you to do that. I find it kind of
repulsive
I think
Oh, can I get Does anybody know the timeline on this? When did
the leaks happen that he talked about? Do we have a date on those?
And then because I think it's once she sees the girl that once
he Sorry, once she sees that creepy hoarder girl, I feel like
around that time she's starting to like be weirded out. Oh, maybe
not cuz this is what July when he's going to get gifts.
It's It's very interesting to me. I think a lot of this stuff
is $5. Stay cool, Jay. You don't want to look desperate. You
must act indifferent about playing WoW with Miz. It's important
to not commit too >> I'm definitely not indifferent. I'd
like to play WoW. I just feel like um video games are not good
for me. Okay. I already play I got back into Mar Marvel Rivals
for like 2 seconds and I'm spamming it. I'm like waking up in
the morning, playing for two hours, and going back to sleep.
Not good, man. Not good. Not good. >> And I replied, "No,
I don't want you to do that. I find it kind of repulsive." Here,
Rowan is texting me upset that she has to take down all of the
Hello Kitties from her dorm room. And this next one is probably
the strangest reference to Hello Kitty out of all of them. Here,
she's sending me a video that says, "Get you a man that takes
you to the Hello Kitty hotel."
Crazy how quick you said yes to Miz, but no to us, Rally, and
Loner Box. Um, I had a lot. I was very busy doing stuff at that
point in time. I did not have anywhere near the time. I got the
time now, Amumu.
Big difference.
I I didn't have time back then. >> And under it, she writes,
"Imagine the here." And I say, "I will not imagine." Now, with
some of the more in
the Hello Kitty, I do feel like for sure
she's just consistently memeing on what she thinks is his age
play kink, right?
She just keeps doing it over and over again. And Tom
here and I say, "I will not imagine." Now, with some of the more
insane projections and lies out of the way, I'd like to get into
some strange details that Rowan also decided to lie about for
whatever reason she may have. One thing that a lot of people
pointed out that's strange is that Rowan had taken a photo of
us matching on Tinder before we met in person. >> Um, yeah,
I took a picture of a match because I could kind of tell there
was >> this is where this is where gets crazy. All right.
>> Something weird about this guy. like I didn't know if
he was famous or whatever. And also I did that to other people
as well on Tinder
>> just like everybody mesh with to like gossip with uh
like like girlfriends.
>> That's a lie. That's a lie. That's a lie. That is now
we know an explicit lie. Okay. Based on what Tom >> a couple
of them, but yeah, he seemed like kind of weird. So I took Yeah,
I took pictures of our match. >> She's also stated repeatedly
that she's not a very online person. multiple times. I will say
null could have saved himself here, right? Null could have saved
himself. He could have like made sure he could have expressed
any reticence on this. He could have asked for, you know, any
messages to the friend, any messages to anybody. He really wasn't
looking for contemporaneous evidence of the allegations. He was
mostly just farming for details about Tom's personal life to
embarrass him. I think I think null was just very clearly
yet just looking to embarrass Tom. And it made the interview
it the interview looks worse now in retrospect. It already looked
pretty bad.
I will say maybe null's not having such a bad day though because
in the end the one thing Tom Null wanted to know more than anything
was how big is Tom's dick and it seems like Tom has obliged him
here and let null know how big Tom's dick is. Okay, so maybe
maybe null's actually having an okay day. You know, you win some,
you lose some. s throughout her testimony. But the wild thing
about this is Rowan had sent me a message on my YouTube connected
Instagram.
Ah, he's So, this is huge evidence. Okay.
And maybe I should have looked at covering this up, but I do
think it it probably doesn't matter because of the other stuff
that's happened, but he's about to post an Instagram message.
He once again shows >> But the wild thing about this is
right when it >> hold on. Now, if she still has this avatar
on Instagram or she had it and he's showing the the name and
her name right here, I do believe this is like 2 seconds away
from finding her. You flip open an Instagram, you go Rowan Texas,
and you probably find this person, right? That like this is essentially
doxing her as well. It's pretty stupid to put that in a video.
I do believe he knows precisely what he's doing.
I think there's a little bit of a little plausible deniability
factor that you get from this guy right here.
Yeah. And
yeah, we're starting to people are starting to joke a little
bit. Okay.
Wouldn't let me skip. I don't know what you Oh, nice. Okay. The
the I see what you're saying. The anniversary thing. Got it.
So, there's a little theory going around that the reason Brandon
Buckingham docks this girl is because it's pretty obvious that
Tom was in essence doxing her already and that Brandon Buckingham
was just like, "Fuck it, I'm I'm about to check out anyway, Tom.
I'll I'll hop on this grenade for you." Right. Brandon Buckingham
hopped out of his hospital bed and dove on that grenade for Turkey
Tom. Okay.
Thank God for Brandon Buckingham. the the take overall that because
you're citing a public social media profile, you're not doxing
somebody is the most take I've ever heard in my life. You absolutely
are doxing somebody by connecting a private per like a private
online handle to their real life social media. Absolutely you
are. That is doxing. Everybody knows it's doxing. They only start
saying, "Well, maybe it's not doxing." When they want to protect
somebody they like. That's the only time. Otherwise, you're a
complete,
right, forever arguing that like essentially all doxing, if you
consider a phone book public information, then basically all
doxing is legal and always has been, right? Cuz it's public somewhere.
Willie Mack's wedding website was public. Yeah. Like all of this
stuff is public. Everybody has a public social media profile
of some kind. It's so stupid to pretend that connecting a private
online avatar or private online tag to their public social media,
their their personal social media, like that's not doxing. And
by the way, anybody who writes a law on doxing always includes
that as doxing. It is just obviously doxing every single time.
Now, Tom maybe has a tiny bit of plausible deniability here and
that he said, "Well, I didn't give away the whole name,
but you basically have like the Instagram search is pretty easy.
you've given it's by the way it's Rowan M Rowan M right rm in
the text messages shown so far right whenever he's showing the
hold on let me get the time stamp I'll just go back to one of
these text messages right RM Rowan M how quickly do I find her
you feel like you find her instantly right there's like a tiny
bit of trial and error you know there
>> so this is basically him doxing her
and
I feel like it is absolutely bad that he did this. I do think
she'd have a valid privacy strike against his video. I do think
he sort of engaged in this behavior first. And while I don't
think Tom should be doing it, I think it's obviously bad. You
can criticize Tom, right? Sorry, I'll say she engaged in the
behavior of publishing embarrassing details about Tom. Now, Tom
is responding by publishing embarrassing details as well, right?
So, he's responding in kind. I just I think the extra step of
doxing her personally is probably pretty far out there. I I like
Well, it wouldn't be ethical, Limlet. It wouldn't be ethical.
I'm saying that she went and published like private personal
embarrassing messages about him. So, you might think, well, I
want to get back at you, right? So, it wouldn't be ethical to
begin with. Revenge is not ethical. It wouldn't be ethical to
begin with. But, I'm just saying like I understand where he's
coming from a little bit. And
how do I put this? It's like obviously really bad to do. He shouldn't
have done this. This is like horrible. And I think if you had
concern about Aiden, if you had concern, if you were willing
to back like um Willie Max video about Queenman, right, that
that video now is is totally stupid, right? That that video was
just posting publicly available information
or sorry, the the tweet actually that we looked at was based
on publicly available information. Why did you say Rowan M? I
just went back in the text and shown that it's RM in his text
messages. So, it's Rowan M in his text messages.
It would not be hard to find this person based on the the footage
he's put out here.
Um, and by the way, I've already explained that Brandon Buckingham
fully docks this person. Uh, she's fully doxed in a bunch of
places now, which sucks,
right? It might be
Okay, it might be Oh, interesting. If they changed it so you
could show social media profiles, that might be true, I guess.
Uh, it shouldn't be. That should be something you could privacy
strike with the picture and stuff, but
interesting.
Interesting. Okay. Doxing really should be a felony. Um,
I don't know about that. I think it should be like some civil
case where if you can show malice,
I don't know if it should be a felony.
Unless it's followed up with actual harassment, right? If you
if you can show the malice, then yeah, maybe it should be punished.
It should be punishable. She is not a public figure. No, she's
not a public figure. Maybe you'd argue she became a public figure
when she decided to post stuff, but I I don't think so. Seems
pretty obvious. Like, it sucks because
I think this is the worst
out of the previous allegations,
nothing was actually as bad as doxing this woman.
Like, with the level of proof they had, it was just, you know,
verbal allegations. with the level of proof they had, nothing
that Tom had done so far is as bad as doxing this woman. And
again, I'm weighing the the level of
that they had plus the allegation, right? Like there's a there's
a amplifier for how strong the allegation is. If the allegations
were just true, I wouldn't be saying that obviously.
And it it's just crazy to me that he decided to do this after
the fact. I I can't defend it because I do think
there's multiple ways to look at this,
Is this not also a warning to anybody else who could have an
allegation against Tom in the future? Like, hey, just so you
know, even if I disprove you, I'm still going to make sure you're
worried about your safety. Even if I do, even if you accuse me,
even if I could prove it incorrect, even if you don't hurt me,
I'm still going to come back at you. It's like, okay, that's
kind of sinister.
That's pretty sinister. Maybe maybe I'm a little more convinced
of why Kai decided to come up and go like, "No, no, nothing about
Tom. None of that's correct, guys. None of that's correct." H
I have a feeling I'm going to get more and more annoyed as we
go through this. Give me a second. I'm going to check something
on my phone. One second. One second. I do need to check something
on my phone.
Let me see here. Let me see here.
And I I'm finding more and more people are like, "Oh, yeah, doxing
is just the way it is now." No, it's not. No, it's not. That's
what you say cuz you're angry right now and you want to dox somebody.
No, it's not good.
Give me a second. I need to check. I'm going to see how easily
I can find this person to be honest with you. Give me a second.
I'm guessing they took their [__] down, dude. I think
they already started taking their [__] down. Yeah,
I don't see I don't see any of that there. I just I feel like
you could easily do this with the Instagram search,
but um
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I figure she already deleted stuff, too. Anyway,
it's fine. We should keep looking. It's it's just like now now
there is absolutely a reason why he showed this message and I
will I will give him that at least, right? He could he could
have censored this message more, but this message is sort of
cataclysmic to a ton of her story. All right. Um it's cataclysmic
to a ton of the story. February 21st, 2024, before they'd met
or matched on Instagram or sorry, on Tinder, she messaged Tom,
you have to do a a video on this crazy guy on Twitter. He only
has like 3K followers, but this man is a
She said she didn't know who he was. So, when she took a picture
of the message or the match and said, "Oh, I didn't know who
he was. I just had a bad vibe." She was lying. She was just obviously
lying. Dude,
it's it's actually like totally crazy
that she had this message out here and she lied still about it.
It's so wild, man. I don't know why she
Like that changes a lot of how things are colored for me, right?
Yes, she was a fan.
And this explains to me why she was, you know, not asserting
that she wanted different kinds of or whatever was going on here.
It's cuz she was just a big Turkey Tom fan from the beginning.
She wanted to make this work.
my YouTube connected Instagram all the way back on February 21st
of 2024 15 months before matching me on Tinder where she said,
"You have to do a video on this crazy guy on Twitter who only
has like 3,000 followers, but this man is a menace." I even confronted
her about this when we first hung out because I found it very
strange that she lied to my face when she first met me and said
she didn't know who I was. I said, "Hey, I looked at our messages
on Instagram and saw you DM me over a year ago." Rowan said,
"Oops. Yeah, I'm sorry. I didn't want to." This one is
bad. And it's like it's not even I don't know how to explain
it. It's not even like bad in that it's like not I I don't know.
This was like such an unnecessary lie for no reason.
I none of the none of her actual allegations would look worse.
And she just lied for no reason.
No discernable reason.
I I can tell you why I think she lied and it's sort of something
she says in the Kiwi Farms thread eventually.
Why did you stay with him? Oh, you know, I wanted to get that
bag was what she said. I think she knew Turkey Tom was a rich
YouTuber, so she matched with him and was like, "Oh, I'm just
going to be like the normal person that you're meeting." And
then she realized she couldn't quite do that. And so, she just
pulled back from it and
I was a little bit So, she was a niche internet micro celebrity
on Twitter for a little bit. Yeah.
So, she just I don't know why she lied about this. I think it
was she knew this guy was like a rich YouTuber and wanted to
>> see if it was >> tell you, but I watched one of
your vids a while ago and cute, but I thought it would be awkward.
I responded, "That's okay. I was just surprised." She replied,
"I know I probably look crazy." I said, "I mean a little bit.
It's okay. I just wish you told me, that's all." She answered,
"I didn't want to cuz I thought it would be weird. I'm sorry."
Kind of lied about some stuff. I was like a niche internet micro
celebrity on Twitter for a little bit, too. I'm chronically online
and didn't want to admit it, lol. I've gotten better about >> Once
again, this is Yeah, she just saw one of your videos, Tom. Just
one of them and then she messaged you on Instagram.
She just saw one video one time. That's totally believable, right?
That she saw one video one time and then messaged you. She totally
wasn't like a fan girl at all. No, no, no, no. This is just another
detail that it doesn't even make sense to publicly lie about.
But it's just one of those things that makes me question her
intentions throughout the entire relationship looking back. Publicly,
she's also misrepresented the end of our relationship. In the
interview, it stated that our breakup took place in December
and that after that she realized how bad it was and she felt
the need to contact Katie, who we're going to get into later.
This is blatantly untrue. We broke up on January 10th of this
year, 2026, and she began posting about me on January 14th, literally
days later. She says the
Oh, that hurts too, man. I'll be real. That actually hurts too.
That's actually also bad.
That's not cool, man.
Like, she was obviously just upset about how the relationship
had gone. And we're going to get into some of the messages from
the end of the relationship. And me, do those ever look bad,
too. Those also
>> an idea that is just bitterly ironic because that's
not the case. Immediately after I told Rowan that I wanted to
break up with her, she began threatening to post about me online
and even began attempting to blackmail me into having sex with
her again. I don't know what you want me to say to you. I just
want to move on from our relationship and have you go be in your
your corner. You can meet other guys and it'll be fine. I'll
go meet other girls. We'll just break we'll break up. >> No,
they No, you won't because I'm going to make it hard for you
to ever
have be in a relationship. >> One HP voice. One HP voice
threats. Diabolical combo. Okay. She's not crying. She's not
like It's just one HP voice
threats. That's what she sounds like. She sounds like a child.
That's like a six-year-old threatening you. That's very odd.
>> Because you don't deserve one.
>> I do think I I do think this is also this is like bad
vibes on both ends. This is really really bad vibes on both
I
I don't like this at all. I don't like this at all on both ends
right now. >> Piece of [__]
>> Because you
our whole relationship you act like everything is all about you
the whole
>> You don't give a you
like you're just an awful guy and I'm so sorry that your mom
raised you. She seemed like a nice lady but clearly she did something
very wrong. >> Okay, Rowan. I just want to move on and
have my life.
>> I just think it's weird when you're one-sidedly recording
and you're going to like drive a person like you're going to
laugh at them and drive them to having a certain reaction. I
think he's trying to seem unbothered. He's trying to seem like
calm and put together cuz he knows he's recording. He's like
driving like I that in my head that's what's going on here. He's
like driving her towards now.
Huh? How do I put it? Um I think all that that's that's true.
He's like trying to drive her towards like freaking out on him.
But she's, you know, she's giving in. She is making the >> Move
on and have your life. And
we can be in our own corners. We don't have to do damage to each
other. We don't have to cause each other any more anguish.
>> I just want to see you again, though. Like, do you think
we'll ever be able to see each other? >> After the way
these conversations have gone today, I really don't think so.
Um cuz you're like threatening to blackmail me. >> I'm
not. Well, if you don't come see me, then I will. >> I
stated blatantly that I did not want to have with her. I didn't
want want to be with her anymore. I just wanted out of the relationship.
This is something she was completely unwilling to accept. And
that's why after I stopped Yikes,
yikes. Yikes.
Um
Jesus. I think she obviously wants the relationship to continue.
man, if only if only there were like multiple indications for
months that this is where this was headed. Like hey, this is
it's rough, man. It's rough cuz I think this was easily avoidable
on Tom's end, but yeah, he is um like she obviously has just
tried to destroy him here, right? Like I think that's for this
girl, for the Sacramento girl, I think it's very obvious she
was just explicitly trying to destroy his reputation. there is
no serious allegation going on here whatsoever
and
that Tom I think could be borderline like exonerated on all charges
that she's made. We haven't heard about the Clorox crate Katie
person yet, but this girl is clearly just trying to destroy him.
And I I think it seems pretty obvious that that's where it's
going when you sort of like borderline gaslight somebody on
how serious the relationship is. But it doesn't make anything
she's doing okay. And I think it's pretty up on the other side
to have your trust violated like the way Tom's trust is being
violated here. So >> talking to her, she proceeded to call
me over 30 times and texted me 80 times with no response. She
is publicly dude >> proceeded to call me over 30 times
and >> Oh boy.
I might maybe we'll come back to this and read this. We'll probably
read this whole thing after >> 80 times with no response.
She is publicly claiming to be a victim of sexual abuse while
begging me to [__] her again. like you're you've
done all this like weird [__] like >> Yeah.
Clorox Katie was the one that we didn't think was very serious
before that it seemed like she was pretty obviously just looking
for like
Um yes, >> I don't like it. Like you're so weird. You treat
me badly, especially drinks. And like over over the phone, I
just listed everything that he had done wrong. And he was like,
"Well, you can leave me if you want." And I was like, "Yeah,
I think I'm going to leave you."
That's basically what happened. But there was no like specific
like did you guys talk at all between then between breaking up
and then >> is that is that basically what happened?
>> we basically just mutually parted ways guys. It's basically
just a mutual parting of ways. Nobody to blame.
>> I don't believe
>> Tom is exonerated. Um, I don't know if he's exonerated
on the age play stuff to be honest with you, but like I think
exonerated certainly in the minds of like all of his friends
and I I don't think so. But like for his friends, they would
need a higher standard of proof. They would need more than just
like sort of intuition and what are going on there because they
would professionally disassociate from him. I don't I wouldn't
professionally disassociate from him. So I just don't really
care about that. I think I would lean more likely than not. No,
cuz I blocked him. >> Even this detail is also so insane.
While it is true that once she started to lose her mind, I did
stop talking to her. She continued speaking at me, alternating
between begging me to forgive her for breaking up with her, saying
she wanted to have sex with me again, and sending me psychotic
text messages filled with lies that she came up with once I dumped
her. Now, with Rowan dealt with, the next person I'd like to
address is Clorox Katie K. Damn.
Okay. I do think
Yeah, I just I
I'm trying to think of what could be dangling from that if anything.
Uh it's like it's the age play stuff I think is still dangling
for me, right? Where he he this creepy hoarder girl who was like
an age player on Instagram and
he knew what she was doing. He knew what her pictures were like
and he still went for her. And
I just I it's going to be hard to convince me that there there
wasn't something tangible there. But in terms of all of the bad
possibly criminal allegations, the things that are like sincerely
abusive, I think he's totally
categorically um exonerated on all of those things 100%.
That accusation was in play before this, wasn't it? Well, the
diaper stuff kind of was, but I don't know about age play specifically
before this. I don't think I don't think people had a good idea
of the age >> girl. I had a >> Tom did address it.
Women just called him daddy. What could he do? No. No, that's
not >> address relationship with two years ago. And she
began posting about me on the same day as Rowan. Now, back when
we were hanging out, she flew all the way from California to
Maine to hang out with me twice. In the interview, she describes
her time with me as the worst experience of her life. >> Um,
and then you fly back. And how did that go? How long did you
say? >> Horrible. That was the worst experience of my life,
I think. >> And she also took to the forum to make some
posts about me. Yes, Tom is extremely harsh during I've been
down the kink roads in my life. And how he acts is actually just
evil and almost sadistic. Not even kinkedked up, just actually
a Patrick Baitman type gooner. When asked how things between
us ended, here is what she had to say. I just truly thought he
was a cringe who definitely was going to beat me later if I stayed
around. We only had a two-month fling, but even my insane ass
was scared of how he acted. And he was also >> Dude, I
think we didn't actually read through all those texts. We should
do that before we move on. Not the BWC text, but like these ones
that coming out after. >> Okay. If you don't want to talk
or listen to me, just say that you just say that. Don't waste
my time. You need to apologize. Also, I need $900 from my flight
to Maine cuz it was a waste of money apparently. Goodbye, Tom.
Good luck impressing the next BPD with your limp. I have screenshots
of you talking about Ellie and how your dickpicks were going
to be put all over the internet. You're literally such a re tell
your friend from Dallas to hit me up. Wait, is that Brandon Buckingham?
I don't think so. But my question is, why string me along so
long and didn't you say and say you love me when you didn't?
It became clear to me that at some point
that this would be the response I would get if I were to break
up with you. And I've been dreading that slowly considering you
just told me you were talking to other guys over the phone and
you just threatened to post about me publicly. Realistically,
I can't trust you anyway. Is that why you didn't want to break
up with me? because you were scared I would say some dumb [__]
That is so, bro. I see why you didn't want me to look up
uh look you up because this is so bad. You You're literally just
as bad as the people you make videos about. Like a Bel Deline
impersonator and getting your leaked is crazy. And then telling
your girlfriend about it expecting sympathy. Have some self-awareness.
You're really just an overgrown manchild in some ways. Ohio impressed.
But also, I need my money back because you should have told me
before the trip to break up with me.
Um, oh, right. They went to Maine. I'm guessing she flew to Maine
with him. It wouldn't have been Mass, right? It was Maine that
they went to go see his parents. Oh, Auggie. Maybe it was Auggie.
Who knows? Also, I need my money back. You literally sit at home
all day and so and do nothing. Have no hobbies except for gym
and video games. Have a high body count, but you think you're
high this high value man. It's crazy. I know whichever girl is
unfortunate enough to get into a relationship with you next will
go through the same thing I did because you're like actually
so emotionless and mean. Also, you're like mad chopped in the
face and I had to look past it. Ah, bro.
The Bulgarian jeans getting called out in real time. Uhoh.
That's Dude, you you're like mad chopped in the face 80 times
with no
boys. Uh, that's rough. That's rough. That's rough. That's rough.
Um, I'm done being a hater. You have a lawyer. You can't record
me without consent. Posting text screenshots is an illegal dumbass.
So, I think I think
that this is talking about voice recordings, by the way, not
recordings. I think it's very likely this talk about their conversational
recordings. Why do exes say like that? >> No response.
>> You ugly.
>> You dated him for months. >> Um, I don't know.
You're literally so stupid, Tom. I should have gone to the police
right away, but I have evidence. I told my
roommate after as well as my friend Sophia. You can't even deny
it because this for real happened and you said word for word
I like hurting you. I still remember because of how it felt.
I'm getting a no contact order. It will go on your record. You're
a [__] narcissist. I also got a lawyer. I hated having
to tell my mom. You're a genuinely genuinely horrible human being.
You're genuinely a horrible human being. I never loved you. I
just love the idea of you. I'm going to courthouse in Waco. When
I get there ordering a temporary restraining order due to past
threats you made against me. It might go to a real court in which
both of us will have to appear. Yeah. He still claiming to be
a victim of sexual abuse while begging me to [__]
her again. >> Like you're >> How did she find out
he had a lawyer?
Okay, hold on. We We've got to move past this. But I'll look
one more time. I'll look one more time here. Give me a second.
It's after >> he proceeded to call me a victim of abuse.
Me 80. >> Hold on. You have a lawyer? Oh, I think this
is because they just talked over They just called. They just
talked. That's I I think possibly the recording he just showed
is right here. I think this is like I think because they talked
over voice. I think they they somehow called each other to be
honest. Anyway,
>> back to breaking up and then
>> um Tom and I get like >> he proceeded to call
be a
while begging me to her again >> is at me alternating between
begging me to forgive her for breaking up with her saying she
wanted to have sex with me again and sending me psychotic text
messages filled with lies that she came up with once I dumped
her.
>> Okay, I'm going to grab more caffeine really quickly.
Now, with Rowan dealt with, the next person I'd like to address
is Clorox Katie. Katie is a girl I had a brief relationship with
2 years ago, and she began posting about me on the same day as
Rowan. Now, back when we were hanging out, she flew all the way
from California to Maine to hang out with me twice. In the interview,
she describes her time with me as the worst experience of her
life. >> Um, and then you fly back and how did that go?
How long did you say? >> Horrible. That was the worst experience
of my life, I think. >> And she also took to the forum
to make some posts about me. Yes, Tom is extremely harsh during
I've been down the kink roads in my life. And how he acts is
actually just evil and almost sadistic. Not even kinkedked up,
just actually a Patrick Baitman type gooner. When asked how things
between us ended, here is what she had to say. I just truly thought
he was a cringe who definitely was going to beat me later if
I stayed around. We only had a two-month fling, but even my insane
ass was scared of how he acted and he was also just stupid. I
hated conversation with him. He was just extremely weird to me
and also evil as during naturally people asked her why she hadn't
reported me to the police and her response was I thought about
the police and looked into it but again it being across my own
state line.
So yeah these allegations I'm trying to think of like why we
sort of doubted this person from before.
I think it was a lot of their connections to online stuff.
Oh man, there was some other she was posting a lot more in KF.
I'm trying to think of like other reasons we had like a little
bit less confidence in these allegations. She was the only one
who posted like the bruise or whatever.
I'm not sure how Tom will categorically respond to that other
than he can point out that she was saying on Kiwi Farms it was
the worst experience of her life and that's not what she was
saying in Maine. It would have had to been filed there and I
lived on the opposite side of the country so it just didn't seem
feasible. These claims are once again so absurd to me that the
best way to dispel them is to just look through.
>> That's um that was a call we made here right off the
bat with Clorox Katie. The second she responded to somebody asking
her a question. Oh, the Sacramento person too where it's like
I I'm going to prove that I'm not crazy or I don't have BPD when
you need to like make them like you. The second you do that I'm
like oh you are these people will hate you the second you're
not useful to them. like you are so if you're trying to make
these people like you. This was the Jet Neptune. >> Our
messages together. In these two DMs, you see that Katie comes
to visit me for the first time on January 20th and leaves on
January 23rd. She comes to visit me. She says she's excited.
She then goes home. And after leaving my house the first time,
she immediately texted me saying, "I had so much fun, Tom. You
can kidnap me whenever. I feel so alone in my bed." She then
says that she has to come back. Now, days after coming the first
time, she sends me nudes. Once again, this is kind of a weird
thing to send to somebody that you're claiming is recording with
you without your consent. Why would you send this person nudes?
Uh, she then sends me nudes a second time. Says she needs it.
Says, "So starved, so deprived, and she says that she misses
me so much." I say, "Let's hang out in March." She says, "I'm
down, but waiting until March will be so hard." On February 1st,
Katie says that she misses me. On February 2nd, she slides up
on my story and says she is counting down the days until she
can see me again. She then says that she needs to see me. ASAP
and she misses all the things about me. On February 4th, she
says she wishes that she woke up cuddling me. On February 8th,
she says she wants to have sex with me again. Once again, this
is after the first time we hung out. February 18th, she says
she's going to swallow me. And she then sends me naked photos
of herself willingly. Keep in mind, once again, she's accusing
me of recording with her without her consent. And then she keeps
sending me naked photos of herself. She even sent me a video,
by the way. Uh she
>> I mean I H like I normally have a response here of
okay but does this mean very much like okay
like normally when people do this like oh they still wanted to
be with me it's like well it doesn't doesn't necessarily mean
that you couldn't be insulted right or or recorded without your
consent but then she when she talks about it she says it's the
worst experience of her life like it they don't match at all
so when she's making the allegation she talks about how much
this doesn't
how much she hated it and she's describing how much she loved
wants to hang out with him again. Now, a lot of that is the YouTube
clout working in his favor, right? That even if it went badly
the first time, she wants to hang out with like the big YouTuber
again, she's going to say that things went well, even if they
didn't. But I don't know, man. It's it's really difficult for
me to believe this when it's just so so
far apart. Like, the two stories you've told are so far apart.
Like, what he can show in text and what you've said is so far
away from what was actually said. >> Says, "I need you
right meow. I need you ASAP. February 22nd and February 24th,
we have I miss you and are you home yet? February 28th, she slides
up on my story and says, "I am going to suck you so good." She
then says, "I need to see you now more than ever. Lots of hugs
and hot." On March 2nd, she says, "I like you lots and I reciprocate."
She says she can't wait to see me again. She then says that she's
excited to see me that coming Saturday. In the next screenshot,
I say, "Your pussy's going to be so sore." And Katie responds
with, "Good thing we had to wait a while because then I can take
a beating." She then says, "I'm ready for you to throw me around."
Now, when we were discussing how many days she would want to
stay, she says, "As long as you want, and that we'll have so
much and party so hard." And she then once again expresses how
excited she is. On March 7th, she sends me a barrage of unsolicited
photos, including her with BDSM leather on her butt. On March
8th, she says all she can think about is me, and she can't wait
for my dick to be down her throat. And on March 10th at 7:00
in the morning, which is 4:00 a.m. her time, she says that she
is so excited to see me that she cannot sleep. Now, with the
Instagram messages out of the way, we can move on to the text
messages. So, on March 10th, this is the the the second visit,
right prior to getting there, she says that she is starving for
me. Now, March 15th, uh this is when she leaves, she says, "I
still have her toothbrush, but that I have to let her come back."
Now, keep in mind, Katie, in her own words, said that this second
time visiting me was the worst experience of her entire life.
>> How long did you say? >> Horrible. That was the
worst experience of my life, I think. >> She basically
describes being physically abused in the interview. She even
says that while we were having, she would ask me to stop doing
something and I wouldn't, but that did not happen. You may also
recall her stating that she ended things with me because I was
such an insufferable person to be around. She claims that after
the second trip, she began to realize she was a victim. >> Yeah.
And that's kind of like when things really started piecing together
to me that I was like, "Wait, I think I am a victim right now.
Like something's not right here." >> In her words, this
is why Hold on a second. I just sent a message in Misgiv's chat
just >> wait just asked. I guess I could just give it to
him. We'll see.
>> Um I show speeds. Who's stale?
>> Stale. Can you give your background
>> Uh sure. So I was the uh the former top moderator of
live stream. Um I also used to work at Twitch for four years.
I built the clip system videos.
>> Yeah, it was it was a funny >> you know I got
a little carried away I would say with with some of those videos
but I can be more more serious. >> No. Here's why I love
it still. It's cuz you're passionate. I love people with
>> Like like you you have passion and I I love that because
you're right in a lot of things you say. >> I We'll see
if he gets that message. I let him know that I'm down
>> He did your like hate posts.
>> No. No. What? No. Him. >> But I'm getting >> live
stream fails. >> No. You're thinking that was the >> He
was a moderator. >> What is that? >> Okay. All right.
I'm good. We're back to Turkey Tom. There's a lot more stuff
after this with Turkey Tom. So, we'll see what all gets said.
Okay.
How is Lizzy on Misk's screen right now? Uh Lindsay said she
was going to play WoW. I think >> she stopped talking to
me. She said she was scared of me. She said she was scared that
I would beat her. Well, on March 20th, which is after the second
visit, she texts me saying, "Tom, I really like spending time
with you, but I'm kind of worried about if you actually like
me or just using me." LOL. I'm just bpding and so I'm tweaking
and need reassurance. Are you just having fun with me or do we
have something? to which I respond, "Well, I like you and I think
you're cool and perhaps we even have something. However, I would
make a bad boyfriend, so I don't really want to date anyone officially."
Yeah, that's
It's so funny that I point out the obvious, well, trying to keep
a girl in the friend zone kind of thing. It is It is just the
same thing where it's like, well, I don't know, dude. ever doing
this to people is just like um
you should try to extinguish all hope. If you have no interest
in a relationship with somebody and they're like get you could
tell they're getting feelings for you. The compassionate thing
to do is to literally extinguish all hope. Say I'm not interested.
I'm never going to be interested.
I'm
this will never happen. Sorry. Like that's that's the comp easier
said than done. It is easier said than done and you probably
need to go through some example like this in your life, right?
Where you have where you kind of like aren't willing to do that
and things go badly for you. If you don't want it, then you need
to extinguish all hope. You need to say, "No, no, no, no, no,
no. We're not doing it. No, it's not a thing. This will never
be a thing."
Okay? This like passive aggress like
uh dare I say avoidant way of doing it. Oh, I'd just be, you
know, I'm just not ready for a relationship right now. I'm just
not ready for like that. I I don't know if we'd be good match.
I don't know. Like I'm I'd be like a bad >> I guess. Yeah.
I was abundantly clear with my intentions with her. I did not
want anything serious at that time, but apparently this is the
period.
>> Um I think you only do this if you need, which is just
like a weak mindset. Okay. What? Who's the one who said it? Masterson.
I think if you need to [__] all the time, that's
like feminine. You're basically like a gay man if you need to
[__] all the time. Okay, if you have to constantly
just all the time, you're like a total
you're like actually gay. You're basically a woman. Okay,
that's that's just facts. If you can't go without if you have
to be a terrible person to get, then I don't know. Perhaps you
should figure out how to deal with life without it. Wow. If this
person's throwing you, wouldn't you just like take somebody up
on that?
I mean, maybe depending on what was expected. She began to realize
the true extent of my abuse, which is probably why after we had
already hung out the second time, Katie tries to arrange a third
meeting with me, saying she wishes that she was in Ohio where
I was. >> Oh, so that kind of categorically blows this
up too where she's like, I after the second meeting, I knew he
was totally up. He was just going to like abuse me. I'd never
talk to him again. >> That's at the time. And I did not
reciprocate. After this proposition, she slid up on my Instagram
story 12 times over the next 10 months. And I did not slide up
on her story once. Not a single time. So ask yourself, do these
texts sound like a girl texting a guy that she finds evil and
sadistic? A guy that she was even debating going to the police
about? Because to me, it seems equals gay. No. Needing to get
laid so badly that you will lie to people
is gay. Okay. If you have to lie to people, if you can't be yourself,
if you can't just like be honest with people, you got to lie
to people to get laid, you like kind of suck. You're like kind
of feminine. Maybe not gay. You're just like a feminine man.
That's how it is.
No, I'm not scared of so clear. >> I'm not saying that.
I'm saying just listen to the words I say. If by the way, if
you can't interpret this correctly,
if you can interpret this correctly, if you hear me saying I
don't like or I don't like getting laid, you're somebody who
is this feminine man I'm describing and you're upset about it.
Yeah, I lie to women. That's the only way I get laid. I have
to lie to women. I have to lie to women about everything to get
laid. What am I supposed to like tell them the truth? That's
just you. You're just upset. >> Enjoyed our time together
and even wanted to hang out a third time. You got to keep in
mind here, she flew across the entire North American continent
twice from California to Maine to see me. After the second time,
she wanted me to be her boyfriend. I didn't want to. And she
then repeatedly made efforts to contact me and hang out with
me again. Now, to close off the video, I think I'd like to share
some interesting texts that Rowan sent me about her dear friend
Katie. as they're both accusing me. >> Oh, this was diabolical
from Tom right here. This is Tom. Tom's about to go on a divide
and conquer campaign right here. Just check this out. >> I
mean, whatever it is they're even trying to say at this point.
After she saw that I was following Katie on Instagram, she messaged
me on December 8th saying, "Did you know Clorox Katie tried to
jet Neptune? Those girls to make themselves easy targets with
uh No, it is feminine. You know how I can prove that? It's real
easy. Um, a lack of self-control is feminine. The need to lie
is feminine. You're engaging in a total lack of self-control
because you need and you're lying to do it. You are acting feminine
across the board.
Dispute any of the premises or [__] off with the
hair and piercings because they have trauma. She then says they
complain about assault a lot because they will anything that
breathes. One month and two days later, I broke up with Rowan
and in the middle of her unhinged tirade about me, she told me
that she would be messaging as many girls I had been with as
possible to try and find whatever dirt she could. so that she
could >> I'm just hoping there aren't that many women viewers
in chat right now. Okay, got a couple I've got a couple of Oilers
who are women who that doesn't apply to at all. Okay, they're
always telling the truth. They're awesome. Please don't stop
supporting the channel. Okay, run to the internet about it. Now,
I've seen a lot of people say things to the effect of uh you
know, Tom's a hypocrite. He gooned. He gooned. Um and you're
right, I did goon. Okay, I did not stop gooning. Um, so
>> do you think the world would end if you went a week
without [__] talking talking about women? I TALK
ABOUT MEN ALL THE TIME. I just spent a whole stream explaining
how despite the fact that Tom has categorically disproven these
allegations, he still kind of seems like an [__]
That's an art. Okay, that's an art.
Maybe in the end the hats are more relevant than ever. Anyway,
that's about it. I've said everything I need to. Uh,
Wow. Yeah. I I feel like Tom Tom categorically disproved the
allegations against him and then went as far as to I believe
doc this talks the women who said about him not Katie but the
one of the women the woman with the hat and then the Rowan girl
and sort of went like actually actually did something to me that's
worse.
I don't get why you would do that man. That seems baffling to
me.
Okay, so Sacramento
threw a little thing out here, a little
Thanks for doxing me, Tom. You going to address DMing miners?
Wait, did he DM a minor? I don't Wait, do I remember this? Wait,
what am I missing with this allegation? Was he DMing minors?
You going to address DMing minors? Who said that? >> I
might have missed that one.
>> Soapbox Society. Thank you very much for the five gifties.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's do it. Let's go. All right.
Does anybody know what this is about? You going to address the
What? I don't recall this one. New allegation is that he was
messaging a 15-year-old. By who? I missed this one. Okay, I missed
it. I'm unaware. I've not been following the Tom stuff for a
little bit. Okay, so she was doing a bunch of like live replies
in that thread. Let me see here. So, she was live responding
to the thread while people were doing this. Let's take a look
at this this post with all of her responses. This is Sacramento.
This is the first girl. Okay. The rowing girl.
No, no, no. She had more responses here as it went along. So,
also, I wasn't bleeding because of my period. And what? You know
damn well. I told you I liked it because I gave into you hitting
me in the [__] face. You are Tom. Also, your dick
isn't that big. You ugly
A lot of those texts are corrupt and taken out of context.
I think the thread the thread had kind of turned on her. Okay.
The thread had kind of turned on her and she was not a huge fan.
All right. Okay. So, we apparently have a different girl who
popped in.
Oh, boy. This is a different girl who popped in a little while
ago. Okay. Hi. I'm trying to reply to your post, but sadly I
need moderator approval. I'm 18 now. Tom followed me on January
11th, 2023, which was actually my 15th birthday. Also, I'm very
sorry that I'm not too familiar with how to navigate Kiwi Farms.
I don't want to put out misin saying he knew I was 15 because
I never told him. Pick related.
Wow.
Okay.
Followed by Jet Neptune.
Jet Jet's never beating the allegations, boys. Jet will never
beat the allegations. Also, oh, wait. Sorry. This is Tom. This
is Tom's profile. Whoops. Whoops. I hit the gas a little too
fast there. I thought I thought it was Jet following the 15-year-old
again. I Sorry. Sorry. I hit the gas a little too fast there.
So Tim would have been 16. No, Tom would not have been 16 in
2023.
She would have been 16. Sorry. Yeah, she would have been She
was 15 in 2023. Tom was what?
20? 21. Tom would have been 20. Yeah. Okay.
All right.
Interesting. So, she says a bunch of the texts are cropped and
taken out of context. I do think there would be some context
missing there, but it seemed like there was a lot of context
in
to make the the to make it make sense. All right. Unless, but
unless because there's one way it doesn't make sense, but then
I'm confused because the way it wouldn't make sense is if the
the context that was cropped was her basically saying, "I don't
want you to record me anymore." "Oh, this was just a joke. I
don't want you to record me." Right? Like for the glasses picture
where she's talking about, "Hey, get these metagasses so you
can film us during." If she said, "Oh, that's just a joke. I
don't want you to film me during that would make a big difference,
right? But if she did, if she had that her saying she didn't
want to be filmed during, why didn't she lead with that? Why
wasn't that a part of her initial allegation?
Right? Because that's usually how I'm going to look at it is
unless she was doing some 40 chess [__] why wasn't
she including the most damning stuff in the first allegation?